in a viral video
you can see russian soldiers preparing
for some kind of conflict
a super chiseled shaven-head russian man
sits him from his bed muscular
then there's another picture of him he's
like in a bomber jet and he's got like a
hood over his head
and then he jumps out and he's got like
a bolt-action rifle or whatever because
it looks like he's got an ak-47 another
anyway the point is this is an ad for
the russian army apparently
and it makes the russians look like
pretty badass and this viral video
then juxtaposes it with the american
army ad which is
a young woman talking about going to
lgbt pride events
in support of her two moms this is
getting slammed by conservatives and i
don't think the
democrats really all you know care that
much of the won't care that much until
it became a culture war issue but ted
cruz
said that the democrats and the woke
media are trying to make our military
into pansies
so across the u.s we've seen the
expansion of critical race theory in
many companies
during the trump era there was a strong
effort to push back donald trump at the
very
at the 11th hour signed his executive
orders to ban critical race theory in
government government trainings and then
any company that contracts with the
government but joe biden has reversed
this
so there's a lot of optimism but there's
also a lot of pessimism
today we've got some people here who
have actually dealt with the expansion
of critical race theory among
uh with from those in their own
organization and how they pushed back
and actually wrote about
how they were able to resist this so
we're going to talk a lot about critical
race theory today where we're currently
at
optimism pessimism of course we have the
military we also have the woman who
wrote the 1619 project
outraged because she was denied tenure
even though apparently it
isn't something she should have actually
gotten and they're claiming now in
mainstream press that it's
cancel culture because she wrote fake
history
and nobody's buying it uh i'm just gonna
throw it to you guys to introduce
yourselves
you know because i know that there's you
know just i'll start with you you go
ahead and you can you can see yeah
thanks for having us yeah i'm grace
and curtis aloha there we go good to be
with you guys
yeah so just you want to give like a
really brief introduction of
yeah sure um so we're co-founders of a
non-profit organization
doing trainings with lay
care providers working with trauma
survivors all over the world
so pretty um high trauma context like
refugee camps and
human trafficking aftercare and foster
kids and
that kind of thing right on so we're
training people who do not have a
clinical background
in how to better support the people they
serve
so you wrote an article for the american
uh was it the american mind yep
about this push for critical race theory
i suppose
yeah all right well then we'll just uh
we'll get into it i suppose do you want
to
add anything to that curtis i
i'm just here so that i don't get fined
okay
good answer all right so so i i think
you know for for this this show
we're gonna be going through like the
whole story start the beginning so it's
probably better we save a little bit of
it so
ian has set up his static orbit yes i'm
ready now the static orb
oh nice thank you tim i'm loving it a
little shea butter on my hands
moisturize ready to rock and roll i love
it
this is gonna be a great show i'm really
excited and i am here in the corner
pushing the buttons for it as always
before we get started we have a really
awesome sponsor just go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com you'll see the
link in the description below
and you can get this really great keto
elevate
mct oil powder you're like what is that
it is
medium chain triglyceride oil powder
you put it in your drinks you put your
food ian's actually put it in his coffee
right now it is so good
it's great it really is it's like it's
creamy and delicious it even says
creaminess it really does make it like
creamy
so you can put in your coffee this is
really great if you're doing keto that's
why they say over at the biotrust
website
they say the keto diet the keto diet
works wonders if you go to eat right and
feel well.com
you can get 51 off right now so this
stuff's great i love putting it in
drinks smoothies obviously ian's adding
it and that's really what it's like
it's like energy it's it's fat it's not
nasty sugar it's 100 c8 mct
and when you go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com you can get a
60-day money-back guarantee
and they say that the product provides
enhanced enhanced energy levels
healthy appetite management enhanced
mental clarity and focus athletic
performance
keto elevate is very gentle on your
stomach five grams of the highly sought
after
mctc8 per scoop keto elevate is the most
advanced mct powder on the market today
free shipping in every order and here's
the cool part for every order
biotrust donates a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org
to date biotrust has provided over 4.4
million meals to hungry kids so please
help
biotrust hit their goal of 5 million
meals this year
and you get a free vip live health and
fitness coaching
from biotrust team of expert nutrition
and health coaches
for life with every order that's that's
like the craziest thing whenever i read
this i'm like
wow talk about value free new e-report
the top 14 ketogenic foods with every
order
keto is so popular right now like
everybody's doing it i recently we just
bought a bunch of like keto cereal and
keto cookies
yeah i don't want to be eating like
cupcakes whatever nonsense so we have
like this like they're like just
it's just good snacks to have because we
have like a bowl of fruit roll-ups or
whatever and so when people come here we
just
like here's i'm like maybe we should
give them the trash and then you keep
the ketosis no no no we're putting the
good healthier like i'm buying healthier
i'm buying a lot of healthier stuff
that's good so that when people show up
we're not just shoveling candy down
their throat so again go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com the link is in
the description below
and thank you very much biotrust but
don't forget go to timcast.com become a
member
we have a huge library of awesome
members only content
when you sign up to be a member you're
really helping us grow the business
because we are talking with a bunch of
other producers about new shows so
teamcast.com is going to have
a ton of content so that that membership
is going to go a long way but
we are very close to opening up every
friday night
as a semi public event which means
sign up those that give at least 25
bucks a month
will be we'll we'll we'll see the
announcement and we're doing 10 first
come first serve tickets for those that
are you know big fans and you're able to
catch the article
and then we're doing 10 auction tickets
so it's like to the highest bidder and
we're trying to find a way to balance
getting as much opportunity to everybody
who don't have the time or who don't
have the resources
it's not easy it's not perfect but sign
up because that will be coming soon
we just got to get through a lot of the
business work to make it you know on the
level you can't just
invite a bunch of people to a building
you know there's there's laws and stuff
but uh
definitely do it and don't forget to
like and subscribe to this channel like
like this video subscribe and share the
show with your friends because we're
gonna get serious right now
let's jump in to our story so this is
the
article the american mind you can hold
your
you can hold your ground against
critical theory
and there's this image of a bunch of
very angry people with pitchforks and
baseball bats shovels
one guy's got an axe yeah that's i've i
i i've seen angry mobs depicted in
movies but this guy's got an axe and
he's wearing some kind of ballistic
helmet
that's a pretty serious graphic they got
there but uh i don't i don't think what
you were
you guys were going through involved
people with axes chasing you
not literally no no not literally but uh
i guess the gist of your story is that
you run an organization
and wokeness critical racers started to
emerge and
you guys fought back so why don't you
just tell me from the beginning like
what happened
yeah so i actually joined twitter
almost a year ago because we
were dealing with what we could tell
were some sort of ideological
um strains of thought happening within
the organization
and with those strains of thought some
very specific
um strongly worded requests around how
the organization should proceed so what
does your organization do
right so we're doing the trainings for
people who work with
survivors of trauma so we're training
lay people so people who do not have
clinical training
um in how to better serve the people
that they
are helping cool so then uh so what
happened with these ideologies
so yeah so it's connected to you know
psychology counseling
and those fields are
influenced now in part by critical
theory which is an academic theory
and while most people i mean i think the
language is kind of a hard part about
this because
you know when you use the word like woke
it's really loaded and it's becoming
kind of a pejorative and people will
resist that and
you know like okay you're just using
woke to say like anything i don't like
that's coming from the left it's just
sort of this vague word
that catches everything and you don't
even really know what it means
um so let's so so if you don't mind uh
how about i just i'll pull up critical
theory
as wikipedia defines it not the perfect
definition but for those that we want to
avoid you know loaded phrases
they say critical theory is a marxist
approach to social philosophy that
focuses on reflective assessment
and critique of society and culture in
order to reveal and challenge power
structures
with origins and sociology and literary
criticism it argues that social problems
are influenced
and created more by societal structures
and cultural assumptions than by
individual
and psychological factors maintaining
that ideology is
the principal obstacle to human
liberation critical theory was
established as a school of thought
primarily by the frankfurt school
theor theoreticians theoreticians
theoreticians
herbert marcuse theodor adorno walter
benjamin eric fromm
and max horkheimer huawei described a
theory as critical in so far as it seeks
to
liberate human beings from the
circumstances that enslave them
yeah so this is what marxist liberation
from systems of power and oppression
orchestrated by humans on behalf of
other humans or humans collectivizing in
order to liberate themselves
from hegemonic oppression so yeah
definitely marxian in nature
the thing is though and where it gets
hard is even though
people are very influenced by the ideas
of critical theory and we're seeing this
all over our country at this point you
know in schools in the military in
medicine um
a lot of people who have embraced the
ideas of critical theory
don't wouldn't call it that they don't
know they wouldn't say oh i'm a critical
theorist i believe in critical theory so
while they're while they have accepted
many of the tenets and they're using the
jargon like oh there are systems
of power and oppression and we need to
you know we need to examine
these power structures and make sure
that we're not complicit in perpetrating
abuses or perpetrating oppression so
we're all familiar with that language at
this point
if you were to you know ask the average
person like oh like where would you say
your ideas are coming from they might
say something just like social justice
it's social justice i'm doing social
justice and so it's like that's great
i'm for that you know
but they're not maybe aware of the
actual roots of this thing and how
it the aims of it you know um
and so they end up aligning themselves
with a theory
that is fundamentally and i mean this is
why i think it's so important to speak
out about it is it's dehumanizing
um definitely so and we felt that and so
i mean in terms of that image being
somewhat
um sensational with all the pitchforks
and whatnot it still is
and other people many other people
because when i when i i posted this
story on twitter and it ended up
being spread abroad and so well let's
start uh
i'll start from the i'll give you i'll
give you a left argument i suppose
critical theory theorists argument yeah
so you you run this organization
and you start noticing you start
noticing this ideology
the first question you'll probably get
is well what's wrong
with someone speaking up and trying to
have you know racial justice within your
company
are you against that no not at all in
fact i share those same values and i
think we might different strategy
and then what happens is when you say i
differ in strategy they say it sounds
like maybe you're
unwilling to investigate your white
privilege or your whiteness or how
you're complicit in this system it
sounds like you're not really ready to
talk so
it quickly shifts from the idea to you
what was the first thing that happened
that uh
that you noticed right so actually the
first
time the rubber really met the road we
were like okay wait a minute so
first of all curtis runs the staff i'm
technically a volunteer for the
organization
and have been on the board the governing
board i couldn't help but notice that
curtis is a white male
you are correct he's also straight
oh he's also cisgendered oh no are you a
christian he's a christian
i'm going to pass out what's the five
things
oh man that's like way more um but i
jokingly i i jokingly but i do bring it
up because i'm sure that
with him running the staff absolutely
that was immediately a point that people
brought up so
again i i i shouldn't uh interrupt but
you know so no no notice
no it's an important point um well i
mean he might be able to speak to this
more because
it was he was beginning to feel like i
don't even have the right
to or it's hard for me to contradict my
own staff in certain ways
um based on how they're presenting these
things to me as though these are
non-negotiables well so so what were
they presenting like what happened
yeah um i mean
so i would say that the first time that
i
felt like we i ever kind of even hit the
pause button because i
first of all i hired all these people i
love these people they're not
people that are carrying pitchforks
exactly i mean when you try to have
these conversations
of course you're you're being you're
trying to get people's attention so i'm
glad that that we are
attentive to this conversation now and
so all these people i hired them they
did great work in so many ways for so
many years
we i'm proud of what we accomplished
together and i love and care about them
and it was an honor to partner together
as well as support them
in in all the ways that i was able to
and the first time that i ever felt the
need to push pause
on and really kind of analyze their
approach to
providing the mental health resources
that our organization's mission
uh offers was when affirmative care
came up and when we were trying to talk
through our guidelines of really being
welcoming inclusive and a space that of
course the shared value
of everybody being able to have access
to
what we had to offer and to feel
comfortable
and and uh be able to uh
receive from that time in that
educational space so it
that is where things began to surface
was around
the strategy of how to uh welcome
and include people and so right and
specifically around gender identity and
the use of gender pronouns
so it was it was an issue of speech and
compelled speech because at first
was it was this you guys introducing a
policy or is this something brought to
you
like wanting a new policy no so the the
our the way
the organization is structured is we're
training organizations we have trainers
who are
contract employees who are all over the
world you know they
are scattered different places and they
lead trainings for us and then we have a
central
team at headquarters that that oversees
the training program
so those training program staff that
began you know wanting to introduce into
the curriculum this idea
of we should be actually teaching the
people at our trainings about
gender identity and a good way to model
that is
to actually more than invite them at
first and they they eventually realized
their their first approach was not the
best but their first approach was
everyone needs to share a pronoun
whether you know what that you know
whether that's your thing or whatever
like we're gonna we're gonna have the
whole circle share their gender pronouns
i mean there were comical moments
because like we train everybody in the
world and
even the people who come to where we are
locally and are trained with us
are coming from all over the world so
there are many languages in the
languages that
don't have pronouns uh that's a good or
like non-gendered ones like
these trainings that were happening
locally were done in english so anyone
who was there was an english speaker but
yes we did we train in other languages
as well and in contexts where yeah
absolutely this category of gender
identity would just be
completely foreign and inappropriate to
bring up but
um this in the local trainings you know
we'd have moments where you know
a woman from uganda was there at the
training and it gets to her and she's
just like
i don't know what you're talking about
you know like i don't know so it's like
how is this inclusive like you're making
her feel
like she's no idea what's going on this
you know and so they they backpedaled
from that
but um it was still their deeply held
conviction
that if you don't bring that category of
gender identity into the space as they
would say it
the people who that category is
important to their identity will feel
erased essentially
um and it's a very egocentric yes
like world view right right my my
experience
trumps yours yes right
um and the the fact also
that even though some of our training
staff were licensed
clinical mental health professionals
these training spaces are not clinical
spaces
so there was that thing too like wait a
minute like how can we be doing
care like this is a this is a clinical
model of care affirmative care like we
shouldn't even be touching it at all
we're training we're an educational
space
no one is signing confidentiality
waivers to be here
no one is receiving therapeutic care
from you
um and so that just kind of that is what
ripped off
the the lid to all of this because i
just was like i don't know what they're
talking
about i don't know why this is such a
big deal to them i don't get it at all
i need to start doing some reading um
and this was probably like three years
ago
it's been it was yeah and that i really
started like
i using some of the jargon that i heard
from them
on a regular basis i just started
reading so intersectionality you know it
was a big word that i heard them use and
um
that was kind of where i started and
then that that launched me into this
world of critical theory this is why i
say welcome i don't say critical theory
critical theory is one aspect of what
exactly what we're seeing but
then you have intersectionality then you
have fourth wave feminism and all these
different ideas
and so i understand that you know woke
might be loaded because you've got a
culture war going on but
it's more of an umbrella term for a
variety of authoritarian ideology
right it's it's very it's it's uh uh
it's a moral
framework that believes in their own
superiority much like
many fundamentalist religions it's
unassailable you can't examine it you
can't challenge it
right so so that to me was what raised
the red flags was like
hey i'm i'm totally happy for you to
disagree with me like that's why we
hired the diverse people
you know we wanted the strength that
comes from different perspectives but
when you tell me i must accept
your conception of reality and i can't
even ask questions because asking
questions alone reveals that i'm
i'm revealing like my resistance to even
being a good person or something by
asking questions
like oh i don't want to investigate my
cis heteronormative
you know whatever um i was like you know
that to me is like cultish language you
know where it's like
this this doctrine must be accepted and
to ask
is proof first of all first of all that
the injustice is happening that you're
questioning you know what is ibrahim x
kennedy's always saying the heartbeat of
racism is denial
so so it's this proving that he himself
is one of the most
abhorrent racists in the planet i mean
that literally yeah
by his own world view the man himself is
one of the most unrepentant
and that's a really important point is
you have to hold them to the standards
that they're holding to you
and then when you hold them to those
standards that's when you start to
realize like wait a minute this isn't
actually about
a good faith dialogue because i just
applied your standard to you but now
you're
it's there's it's asymmetrical exactly
so
you know uh we'll put up we'll put a pin
in that and then for for the people who
watch
the show and know me they've probably
heard this but just to you know for
those for you guys who haven't heard it
when my experience my first experience
with critical race theory
intersectionality during occupy was if i
agreed with them
they would they would recognize my mixed
heritage if i disagree with them they
would accuse me of being a wealthy white
male
clearly none of that was true but it was
just if you disagree with us
you're a white man and then i'm like
well my mom is actually and i'm from the
south side i'm poor and they're like oh
i'm so sorry
oh you know so just depending on none of
your ideas changed it's just like now
they've reframed
they they i was told explicitly that i
you know needed to reconsider my
opinions as a white man and then when i
explained actually i'm a high school
dropout from the south side of chicago
and from a mixed race family
then all of a sudden these white
liberals went oh
oh now i see what you're saying like
legit also now i was like oh i'm like
the most disrespectful and insane thing
i ever experienced i was like what are
you
what what is this like do you have an
actual author well it's reductive
and that's the dehumanizing part is it's
reductive for the person who's on the
receiving end of that you know to
literally be told you cannot speak on
this topic because you are
xyz like you just don't even get a seat
at the table but then it's i think it's
dehumanizing for the person who is
holding the view and so
equally equally like i'm concerned about
um the people who are being treated this
way and you know having their
their lives ruined because they're being
cancelled or whatever they're they're
going to lose their job they're going to
be smeared and you know in
all the newspapers and their and their
you know reputation is in shambles at
the end of it
um and i'm concerned for them but i'm
also concerned for the people who have
bought into it
because it's it's really a dangerous way
to look at other human beings
so after you start noticing this this is
critical gender theory stuff popping up
yeah
you mentioned that they realized it
wasn't working so they changed their
tactic or whatever
well just like so so walk us through
what's what's the next thing that
happens
well actually i really appreciate how
you defined terms for us at the
beginning and read that definition of
critical theory that's super helpful
um and that's kind of the next tack we
took was like okay it seems like we're
talking two different languages
like we're saying no we're we're doing
justice like that's why we started this
organization
it's about justice it's about you know
disparities in mental health care that
you know most of the world that needs
mental health care doesn't have the
resources they need that's why this
organization exists
and you're telling us that we're not
doing justice so i think we need to
define some terms you know so we really
started there
um i can't remember which the first one
was that i did but i just started
cranking out organizational
position papers that essentially defined
terms and and we
we at that point we had entered into
like a formal
um series of i don't know better word
for it than struggle sessions
it was these all org meetings with the
board chair president sometimes a third
party mediator present
trying to just even figure out like what
what is needed where is the harm you
know because there's all these
accusations of this organization is
causing harm there is harm but it was
always in that kind of passive voice you
know like
it wasn't ever like you harmed me when
you said this
there is harm there is harm um and so
we were like okay first thing we need to
define is psychological safety what does
it mean because that that term is being
thrown around you know like
psychological safety has been violated
um i can't even trust you know i can't
have a conversation with you
with your ideas or whatever the things
you've said it's like okay
fine let's look up what psychological
safety actually is and define it
and we defined it based on the coddling
of the american mind i don't know if
you're familiar with that book but
i'm jonathan hype jonathan height and
greg lucanoff and um
so they really go into like the
psychology behind what's sort of
happening on university campuses
right now and now has you know like
overflowed into the whole
culture um and so i used a lot of the
material from that book
and then um amy edmondson is a professor
at harvard business school who coined
the term psychological safety and i used
a lot of her research
and then i used some trauma-informed
models of psychological safety which is
you know we do trauma work so
um very much all in alignment with each
other so you've got this like business
school perspective you've got these guys
who wrote this book about the phenomenon
of college campuses and you've got
um these trauma-informed groups that
basically teach about how to be safe
when you're working with trauma
survivors because it's like a whole
other level of safety right
um and essentially what we saw is
while these people were trying where
they were trying to be helpful
to people who have been hurt you know
it's like yes there's racism yes there
is
you know discrimination against people
with different identities totally agree
but what you're doing when you say like
you like you said this
if you don't speak you know this thing
into the space this person's going to be
erased it's like you're essentially
saying that person has no agency
they're the biggest wimp on the planet
that if people don't like validate them
at every moment and affirm them and clap
for them and and do whatever they say
they're going to fall apart
and dissolve have you seen the dsa
meetings the viral videos
no so this is the democratic socialists
of america
these are a series of viral videos where
if i i wasn't there i can't tell you
what the whole
several hours looked like but in a span
of a few minutes every time someone
spoke they offended someone
and so oh this is the old video i've
seen this yeah a couple years
point of personal privilege one guy says
guys please the chattering is giving me
anxiety
right someone goes don't say guys
exactly sorry yeah
so that's an extreme version of what i
mean right the yeah
but it's what happens when you take all
of those people and put them in the same
room together
well yes it's yeah exactly when your
sense of self is dependent on
others validating you and other others
accommodating you
i think narcissism is a great word for
entitlement is another great word for it
and it's counterintuitive because it's
like yeah if a person's been hurt a lot
um there is a sense of like we need to
take care and we don't want to
you know make them feel unsafe but also
it's like counterintuitive in that
this person probably actually needs to
be
pushed out of their comfort zone you
know so so you're having these company
struggle sessions
i mean it doesn't sound to me like that
like these people actually wanted to
help anyone
it sounded like they just wanted to have
power and bully
i wouldn't characterize in that way they
did they're like the they're
definitely geared towards helping people
but again it's the strategies versus
values
like they they really because i think i
mean you have to applaud them for
living in integrity with the moral
framework that they've adopted like they
they truly believe like this is how
social justice is done
and so they're carrying it out according
to that that conception of reality that
marxian framework that you just read
about
where it says this constant like so so
somebody's in power
and the person who's marginalized or
disenfranchised they have no say in the
conversation so all the norms are just
established by discourse there's nothing
nothing actually objective
see that's that's the real shift is it's
not these
these social categories of race
and biological sex and gender identity
and all these things those are really
weapons towards what is actually under
assault which is objective truth
which is why this whole moral panic
you know that took place over the last
whatever period of time
are um i i kind of think of it as an
epistemological panic it's like it
really
it really disoriented people in terms of
how they know
how they can know whether something is
helpful and true and just
and then and then their methods of
getting to how they know what they know
also we're under salt because
science itself is under assault as a way
to know if you if if
you know you understand their view that
there is you know it's all about power
dynamics
you know the the the ideology the
underlying moral framework
held by critical theorists and the
expanding umbrella is
there is no truth but power that's
that's a core function of their belief
it's
it was one of the core tenants of
fascists right so they're not
ultra nationalists but they hold that
authoritarian worldview which is why
it may be true that there are
individuals who think they're helping by
doing it yes
but certainly it is these are
organizations and these
are uh you know corporations that are
exploiting it for
wealth yeah absolutely i think there are
different
you know varying degrees to which people
understand what they're involved with
right i think
there are certainly people who
understand that this is a tool that can
be used to
radically transform our system of
government and consolidate power
and then like i said they're like the
foot soldiers who are just doing what
they're supposed to do within their
moral framework who
really think that they're helping people
they really see this as like
oh my goodness it's the critical
consciousness right that's the word
that's used that that's where the word
woke comes from is it your consciousness
has finally been awakened to the reality
of power and oppression these structures
of power and oppression that are
everywhere and you just didn't see them
before
so there it's like their mandate now i
mean it's this conversion language right
it's like i was blind but now i see
and so it's like it's so i see this
thing now and these
these poor white straight cis head
whatever people
they don't see how they're oppressing
and so if i if i care about the people
who are being oppressed i have to help
them understand how they're part of the
oppression
just like when i hear from christians
who say
i don't want you to go to hell so i have
to tell you what to teach you
exactly it's like if that's my moral
framework i don't love you if i'm like i
think you're going to hell but i don't
care
good luck yeah you know you know some
issues i'm having with it is
as you said ebermex kennedy said that
denying racism or kennedy kennedy candy
candy candy candy uh that one of the ten
aspects of racism is denying racism but
questioning something
is not denying something that's very
important to understand
and also questioning critical theory for
people to have an issue with that
seems counterintuitive because the whole
point of critical theory is to question
power structure it is so itself should
be questioned that's why i i don't
say you know i hear you'll hear from
people like christopher ruffo it's
critical race theory
well that completely excludes critical
gender theory and that
just excludes everything which is
underneath the umbrella of critical
voice
he is focusing specifically on critical
race theory
right that that's his mission so yes but
the the
terms are really sloppy like you'll hear
people refer broadly to critical race
theory when they mean critical theory
um and that's part of the problem but
it's like i think that's just the
the nature of when a social philosophy
or
a critical theory makes it into the
mainstream and it really just becomes
more about the phraseology the more than
the philosophy so people know the jargon
and they know what you're supposed to do
and what you're supposed to support and
what you're not supposed to support
they don't know the philosophy behind it
i think it's another big mistake
because i've seen that i'm seeing the it
is a it is a huge
failure of the anti-woke to embrace
critical theory as their target
because now what we see are the the woke
left saying
okay name a critical theorist and give
me the idea that you have a problem with
and then what happens is they pull up
specific quotes from like ben shapiro
where he'll read one quote and say well
actually actually i agree with that one
the issue is that
critical theory isn't as a whole the
real problem we're experiencing what
we're experiencing is the fascistic
ideology there is no truth but power
which in many ways is rooted in critical
theorists in frankfurt school et cetera
but it's it's well beyond any particular
identity group race or or gender it is
just a group of people
who will claim harm in any way and
exploit the system in any way and right
now they've found an attack vector
we as a society don't like racism we
don't like bigotry
we don't like discrimination they attack
that
by saying you're being racist when you
try and then ask them what that means
they'll give you a different definition
each time
because it's not critical race theory it
is just an authoritarian
authoritarian fascistic tactic towards
gaining power
yeah and it's incoherent and it's a
double standard but they
are acting according to
the theory which says everything is
socially constructed
so you can continue to reinterpret its
reinterpretations of reinterpretations
of reinterpretations because there's
nothing ultimately real it's
post-modernism it's post-modern
it's post-modern philosophy put into
like a management theory for how to keep
people in line
it seems to me like it's it's what
happens when you have no
moral framework i suppose there is one
there is no truthful power
i think one one of the things i've often
talked about is the difference between
the two factions in the culture war
there's a lot of different definitions
you'll get people will say libertarian
versus authoritarian globalist versus
nationalist lefrost versus right
whatever i think
one uh core separation may be
judeo-christian moral framework versus
absence of moral framework just power
dynamics and so
uh the example i give is bill maher for
instance often talks about how you don't
need religion to be moral however he
believes in many classically liberal
principles which are
founded in judeo-christian moral
framework for instance
the example i often give you know ad
nauseam to the audience who knows this
already is
the fifth amendment a right to a speedy
trial innocent until proven guilty the
right to
remain silent the core of uh innocent
until proven guilty is
blackstone's formulation which was
inspired by the story of sodom and
gomorrah literally out of the bible so
you take away these moral frameworks
bill maher who was raised in a
judeo-christian society who understood
these things but without the religion
doesn't understand how that framework
changes how that how that you know forms
society
and what that means in terms of justice
you now have an entirely
new purely secular religion or whatever
you want to call it non-theistic
religion
with no core moral framework other than
the writings of critical theory
and a bunch of other i mean there's
other non-critical theorists who are
included in their
in their citations often and the ideas
they have is
just get power by any means necessary
period yeah and i think it's a great
point talking about the framework that's
being replaced because i've also heard
as you know everyone's trying to figure
out what do we do about this woke
movement what do we do
is just sort of like just get rid of it
i'm like that's not enough you
you need you need a positive moral
vision
to replace the moral vision that has
become embraced by many people because i
i do agree that it has religious
connotations it's a way of of
understanding yourself in relationship
to the world and then acting out of what
you believe
in a morally integrated way and that
that's the definition of religion
and so it's like okay so you can just
say let's just get rid of of all these
you know critical social justice people
and the woke movement and
that that'll be good like no because
there's clearly like a hunger here for
something
power power yes but belonging
and having having a moral purpose that
you can attach
to clear aims so like that kind of
teleological argument that is like
there's something that we're aiming for
that society is aiming for that each
human being is made
for um and so all of that is is
is providing people with meaning and you
see like very religious kind of
activity coming out of this you know
ritual and confession
and conversion kind of i mean so it's
like you can't just replace that with
nothing
so let's let's we'll go back to uh your
company so you're having these struggle
sessions you decided to define these
definitions
uh what happened next do you want to
share anything
the happy philosopher over there um
well i can step in just to say again
that i want to
again dialogue i appreciate being here
with you guys because
having rich dialogue where there's no
victim villain narratives where you're
honestly
seeking the truth because we're on the
same team the human team
i'd love to just point out in as we
describe this just again that i love
these people
they're intelligent they are caring
they're living consistently with their
convictions and that's exactly how i
want people to live
and so the process for us went from when
we started when we had to push pause and
say hey
okay you know in terms of gender
pronouns like
can't we find a way in which everybody
cannot
have have to violate their conscience
and be able to be here
together and the guidelines in the way
in which we handle that would allow
everybody to show up and learn and take
advantage of that so
um so in terms of of when we did hit
pause and then entering into those
sessions i mean that we were trying to
define terms we were trying to
not just miss each other um same words
different dictionary
um defining words and then also we
started to define the process
and we look for tools so um one tool
that's great which actually we haven't
had a chance to uh
to properly embrace you guys in the
aloha spirit and give you some some swag
from
our organization but i tucked a book in
there that was really helpful for us
our board chair who actually does
professional conflict mediation
um he suggested a book called uh crucial
conversations
and so defining uh what is dialogue
how do we actually have conversations
together where you're you can be
communicating the same definitions of
terms
and you can hear each other and um
and and actually it's kind of fun
because uh they use the term that what
you're doing in good dialogue is that
you're filling the pool
of uh the common and understanding you
want a deep pool
of of being informed so you're trying to
make it a place where some people aren't
just being a fire hydrant and just like
overrunning the conversation and then
other people are like shut off and not
contributing to it you want everybody
to relax and be able to contribute so
that you've got a deep shared pool of
meaning
um for you then to make informed
decisions around so so that's where we
were trying to go to was just yeah we
basically said we need to do it we need
to do this the com
the communication hasn't been healthy
because there are these narratives
forming that like we're these oppressive
people or somebody is oppressing and
causing harm
and there hasn't ever actually been a
concrete accusation of harm so that's
not psychologically safe
because the person who's being accused
is like oh how do i rectify it i don't
know what i did
and you're there's nothing concrete you
know you're not
telling me what i did so how about how
can i apologize yeah
right besides everybody being laden with
the sense of like i'm sorry you're
feeling hurt and i don't even know what
i did
like so that's something in terms of
defining psychological safety
and where not only the same definition
of the term but also
processes where i love it that you know
just having a term like a
crucial conversation where emotions run
high where there's high stakes it means
something
it was very helpful for us to say hey we
want that to become the norm in our
culture
like at the organization that when when
there is something that matters you're
not going to
hide that and have sideline
conversations with other people
if it's you know related to somebody
then they get to take part in that
conversation
and then it also set up a process a
framework by which
you knew that if somebody approached you
and said that i need to have a crucial
conversation
there's you know that i think in the
chinese character for
um crisis is it's danger and opportunity
and i think that applies in terms of
these crucial conversations where it's
like there's danger that something
is at issue here but there's an
opportunity to deal with it as opposed
to
what was happening was there was a lot
of
conflict that was never brought to the
surface and then
that wasn't able to be dealt with in a
healthy way so
so those sessions were about us trying
to
adopt tools that would allow us to have
this conversation properly
and we did continue to dialogue things
you know people didn't leave
immediately we we got a chance to
actually
hear from everybody and fill that shared
pool and then what i think brings us
back to this conversation
about critical theory and whatever we
want to call what's going on right now
um that is the people started to leave
the dialogue
and and that was the question in terms
of if it wasn't
you wore them out they couldn't handle
it they weren't gaining ground and
they're like i'm out of here
to some degree but but it was i mean
yeah the experience that i had
that was just you know disappointing was
it
in sticking to principles i until you
can point out something that we actually
concretely can change um
then to me we haven't done the work
together um
and there were so they said they never
said here's what i want you to do
no they did no there were there were a
lot of different points where
you know open letters were written for
instance with demands in them
what were some of the demands um just
all the stuff that you're hearing at all
the companies like we need to
we need to be more aware of diversity
maybe we need some outside training
we need to be aware of other
perspectives we need to
um we need you know certain kinds of
diversity on the governing board this
that and the other and so it's like all
of these things are great like we we can
you know none of this is something we're
opposed to but it's the manner in which
you're approaching us that's completely
unprofessional and inappropriate
that you would you would go and like
write this letter and then like present
it at a board meeting
like kind of guerilla warfare style or
something it's just like this is not
but so this is why i i i think
you know it's clearly bad faith in in my
opinion from what i'm hearing especially
and it was an attempt to subvert and
steal power and so
that the tactics they use are meant to
maximize damage to you
while minimizing risk to themselves the
the general idea is they can cause you
more harm by
publicly just slapping you in the face
without warning putting you on the spot
where you're forced to say
oh we're okay we'll do it whereas if
they they go to you in private or with
an email then you can
easily push back with minimum risk to
yourself so they
presenting you an open letter at a
meeting yeah common tactics showing up
with a protest i don't
i don't know if you guys experience any
like hard protest but one of the things
they'll do
because then these these corporations
are on the spot
right now will you say yes or no do it
or don't and the corporations panic and
say okay you win
yeah exactly because who wants to be the
target of the next
you know big thing in the media did you
resist it you didn't give in to the
demands
yeah i mean we had the advantages of
being the co-founders of the
organization and so having some
authority
instead of just maybe an employee who's
seeing all of this happening and like
i don't want to be part of this but if i
speak up i'll lose my job
um and also just being you know a
scrappier grassroots non-profit
organization
we're not in the spotlight necessarily
you know we have
a lot of work that we're doing around
the world but um
i just think that we it was worth it to
us to really like lean into that
conversation and try to understand the
ideas and be really principled about
our our push back to those ideas and we
while it was really draining
organizationally like we we spent a lot
of time on that process
that could have been going towards the
work that we're organized to do
um it was it was worth it to
to be able to in a principled way say
we're not going to do these things and
here's why
that's that's another that's essentially
the tactic they know that
you know for a lot of companies they
might say how much money is it going to
cost to do all these trainings and keep
having these meetings i was going to
cost a hundred grand
how much it's going to cost you just
give them what they want 10 20 just do
it just hire somebody
just hire the diversity person whatever
right and then we're done with this
right
but that's a mistake short side because
then you're never done with it and the
long-term effect
is that now you live under it yes yeah
the appeasing strategy doesn't work
and for me it's again i love these
people and over a number of years
i i don't think even in talking with
them when we started to identify some of
the language and we've asked them
explicitly do you
like it seems like you might be adhering
to some of these philosophies is that
the case
um they denied that i don't and i
honestly think it's the truth that they
they weren't aware of it there was
something that they weren't taught it
was something that formally
yeah yeah and it's just something that
was influencing their thinking so my
hope too wasn't just to try to
you know hey i think that my intuitive
sense of this is correct and let's get
there as soon as possible it's like if
you
want to treat people well and you know
be the change you want to see in the
world i want to have
conversations where you can actually
look at the ideas and at the end of the
day the best ideas would be the ones
that influence your policies as an
organization
so it wasn't just to try to hold out and
make it annoying because you know
outlast them it was really my hope was
that
people would come to see that okay we
can have
diversity but we need to unify around
what makes sense for the context of our
organization
and then also again following the logic
of
you know in terms of that one specific
topic can't there be a way in which
somebody doesn't have to compromise
their conscience and everybody can be in
an educational space together
interesting because you know it feels
like a a chinese finger trip
right that most people's instinct would
be to try and pull their fingers out as
hard as possible
and you guys seem to have like leaned in
and really made them explain themselves
and it got to a point where they just
couldn't effectively do it that you know
they talk about harm but
people are probably sitting around
saying i'm so sorry tell us about your
harm and then they can't
i met with every single one of them
individually for as much time as they
wanted to take
because i genuinely cared i don't want
to harm people and i
you know and and yeah i'm sure that they
had an experience that's the thing in
trauma too that like
it's not necessarily about the
experience but the meaning that you make
of it
that that it has an impact on you so
it's even if it's something where it's
like okay
there's no policy or anything that i can
necessarily
fix or adjust i still just wanted to
hear them out because they
it was the experience they had is real
and i care about them but yes we did
have
um you know with the way that things
went where we stick
stuck to the ideas um and then over time
too more came up so
you know when george floyd happened then
that was another big blowup moment of
people wanting to hashtag certain things
and
to advocate and to do things that were
just out of the scope of what we
considered within our mission we don't
make meaning about individuals trauma
and we don't make meaning about
societal trauma at large um we show up
and say hey we've got
rigorously built tools to help people
get through things but we're not going
to make meaning
about what you're getting through that's
just out of our lane we're not
therapists
yeah and so anyways there's some more
you know just kind of dissatisfaction
around that we weren't being more
proactive
about about that in terms of either
advocating
using our social media um or in terms of
doing that work internally as an
organization um
and so that was part of the story was
was that
um it at that point then people started
to and i think this is kind of you know
moving us forward in the conversation at
a certain point
people were not interested in staying in
the dialogue
they weren't interested in looking at
the best research that we could find
around how to actually
you know evaluate our policies and it
got to a point where
people decided to step away and what was
unfortunate and i think
is also reflective of the cultural
moment we're in is that too often
it switches from the ideas that you have
being bad to you being bad
and you know and i everybody's an
individual and
um people when those that did leave the
organization all left in their
own you know way and experience but we
were called some names
and it wasn't our ideas that were
ultimately
um you know
the most uh italicized um
comments so it sounds like though
you're just on the other side of the
culture well now
you could you could choose to agree with
the woke people who are constantly
pressuring you
but it it sounds like you rejected it
and now you're having a conversation
with those who are rejecting
you know critical theory and in the
wokeness and all that
yeah i i mean in thinking about why that
twitter
thread that i posted ended up you know
going as widely as it did and
and bringing a bunch of attention to me
it was that it was just
i mean i i was sad honestly it was like
this should not be rare you know but i
i understand why it is because the
pressure is so great
and people don't want to see their their
organization
you know sued ruined whatever their
reputation ruined and so like you said
they'll appease you know like okay yeah
let's do the training it's no big deal
let's just do the training
but what they don't realize and like
what to his point about um may the best
idea win sure let's engage in dialogue
let's talk about your idea let's talk
about my idea and may the best idea when
that
that is gone because there is no
um there's no more of this idea of of
antithesis right which is how philosophy
was done
forever like from aquinas up until hegel
was like
hey i have an idea i like this idea then
the next i come along is like no i have
an idea this is
this is how we understand knowledge this
is how we have a unified field of
knowledge
and he bumps that up against the last
guy's idea and they're like okay this
idea wins
and on and on and on until hegel where
hegel says
no no we this rationalistic philosophy
project has failed like we are never
going to find unified field of knowledge
so now the best way forward is to
take your thesis your antithesis and
combine them into a synthesis
but what he did in that is he didn't
just change he didn't just go from
that dude's philosophy to this dude's
philosophy he changed the whole rules of
the game of philosophy which was
he established a whole new kind of
epistemology basically saying
well there isn't really an objective
field of knowledge that we can ever find
so let's just do the best that we can to
move things
forward so it wasn't like you know where
you have an idea and i have idea one of
us is closer to the truth
you know we're gonna we're gonna try to
align with truth not just like
move the ratchet forward you know um and
he so he changed that understanding of
epistemology also changed the
methodology by which we arrive
at the right solutions so it's no longer
like we're going to try our best to
align ourselves with what's objectively
real
i had a conversation a long time ago
someone during the occupy wall street
era
who is a far left anti-fog
ultra woke very intelligent
totally educated in philosophy who
completely agreed with me on everything
with one core difference she told me
it's fun to watch the world burn
so while there are probably
the grunts the peons the foot soldiers
of
you know critical theory who just abide
by the tenets that they've been
you know that have been espoused it
seems like there is some truth in this
in the idea of being
woke of truly understanding the nature
of humans and the
philosophy of there is no truth but
power
because it seems like well they're
they're actually in a sense correct of
course there's objective truth
but they know that people will
absolutely give up any notion of truth
for comforting lies and or personal
benefit and that's what they exploit in
which case
i have this conversation with an
individual and we talk about
general philosophy morals nihilism
solidism
et cetera and what a person can know and
what a person can do and why we do it
and we bought we ultimately come to this
conclusion that in the end we're just
kind of being hopeful that what we're
doing is the right thing because we only
know so much right
what is what is saying truism is knowing
that you know nothing and so
my my response was in which case
i'll seek to do the most good uh i want
people to feel better
to flourish to live long healthy lives
to be happy with their families to be
protected safe
life liberty pursuit of happiness and
that means sometimes there's harsh
realities like personal responsibility
you have to work hard and
it might not be easy and she said no i
just want to watch it all get screwed up
and burn it's fun
there's no point if there's no point
there's no end and everyone just chooses
what they want to believe anyway
then let's have some fun with it and
this person's extremely active today
in far-left politics yeah writing books
and holding rallies and
and i know when i see this person their
true intent is
i want people to smash and burn because
at least life isn't boring then
well again she's acting in integrity
with what she has decided is
the the moral framework of the universe
so it's like after hegel
and one of my favorite philosophers
francis schaefer called hegel the line
of despair
so it's like at hegel philosophy changed
and people gave up
the project of understanding
truth objectively and it changed to kind
of coping with this reality that the
universe is absurd
and that there is no meaning attached to
our morality there's no meaning attached
to our language there's no meaning
attached to anything
we do really sad so yeah it's very sad i
mean it ends in nihilism and despair it
has to
because once you remove meaning you
remove hope it's like what's the point
because like one of the john paul sartre
for instance like not
too long after hegel was like this is
where the this is where the trajectory
naturally goes right he
his whole thing was we can't really ever
know
what's what's true what's real and if we
experience something true and real we
wouldn't even be able to communicate it
to someone else or even to ourselves
therefore the only way to like
authenticate your existence is by an
action of the will
but it's still completely disconnected
from meaning and so um
francis shaffer in this book that i was
reading recently used the example of
you're driving down the street in the
rain and you see somebody standing with
an umbrella you stop and you pick them
up and you give them a ride
and you go on and that was an act of the
will that authenticated your
existence but an equal act of the will
that would authenticate your existence
as you're driving in the rain you see
somebody with a
umbrella you run them over equally
authenticating
so who cares you know it's just like and
you're like okay if that's that's where
we've arrived it's like that there's
nothing we can't attach meaning
to to morality we can't attach meaning
to our words
um then yeah why not like so how do you
like say i should do these things you
know because they're kind of shoulds
right i should i
want to be good i want to help i want to
you know i have a
unique moral framework built based
around um
extra p negative entropy and creation
and protection
so i wonder you know a lot of people
believe that
a society can't function without a
religion obviously many people who are
christian or jewish
believe that the united states needs two
main needs to maintain these these judo
judeo-christian moral this this judo
christian moral framework
i agree with them to a great extent but
you know we we've seen a society based
heavily in the moral foundations of
religion and if we went back 100 years
we'd not be happy with that there was a
period where it weakened to a point
where we had
a lot more liberty than we'd ever had in
the past i mean i brought this up
recently
constitutional carry of second amendment
is expanding across the country only the
past 10 years
in the 80s we had a second amendment but
you had less gun rights free speech as
we know it didn't actually get
solidified
i think until like 1961 because we had
that ruling in it was it brandenburg v
ohio or whatever which finally gave us
true free speech as we know it
and there are still restrictions on our
speech so it's interesting to me when i
think about this that
there are many people that they say red
pilled and red build is very much the
alt
the other side of being woke it means
essentially the same thing
yeah but if you look at the average woke
person and the average red-pilled person
they actually aren't awakened too much
of anything they're just aligned with a
political tribe
as you move up higher in the hierarchy i
suppose you'll find
more and more enlightenment my personal
view
of the politics right now from the
high-profile political actors
is that on both sides you have a lot of
high-profile dumb people who don't
really know what they're talking about
don't know anything about
existence philosophy or they can't
self-reflect if i don't meditate
but then i think there's a lot of people
who actually are
truly awakened to something so not
necessarily woke or read pilled but
conscious of philosophy i do however
think those that find themselves on
the ante woke side when understanding
philosophy
are good and generally speaking those on
the woke side are generally
bad and the reason for this is that when
when i started i was
we had a really great discussion about
religion several times actually we
always do these bonus segments they go
for a really long time we talk about
philosophy and religion
i was talking about my moral foundations
and and
you know why i choose to do things that
i do and it stemmed very simply in
what life does and what life does is
organize
free energy into more complex systems
the universe as we think we know it
today assuming we're correct we're
probably wrong it'll probably change in
the future
is that we are looking at the the blip
just after the big bang
and the true state of the universe is
the heat death of the universe where
there's just absolutely nothing every
electron
evenly spaced so far away they can never
interact ever again
we're in this period where entropy rules
the day and the universe is slowly dying
out and spreading out
and so in the meantime there is some
unique organization that is not a
singularity
that creates some kind of interesting
things
free energy organizes itself into
molecules elements eventually
single-celled life forms well actually
first
self-replicating proteins then
single-celled life forms and
multicellular life forms
then multicellular life forms grow to a
point where they started interacting
with each other creating ecosystems
the one thing that we can truly see life
do is organize
create or i shouldn't say create in in
the physical sense
they're not making things they're
organizing and giving structure to
things
the woke are the opposite they're
deconstructivists
they want to take ideas and rip them
apart they want to smash windows
they want to go into organizations and
break them apart
i want to build things and make them
better get rid of the parts that are
vestigial or broken
and slowly improve upon society to the
point where maybe you have a star trek
like future where we're in a spaceship
and we can travel the stars and
have replicators and people are much
more happy and continue the process of
organizing the universe as it were woke
tends to
be a disorganizational and chaotic force
that is a force of entropy of course
a law of the universe and the dominant
one which is a bit a [ __ ]
uh it is a bit oh not youtube's gonna
claim my sword it is a bit
uh depressing but when i look at that
conversation i had with that
woke activist who understood much of
these ideas they chose to be chaos and
destruction
i chose to be creation and order
i view creation and order as good for
very simple reasons like i mentioned
we see life do this but also
who wants to die some people do for some
reason like their body is breaking down
the organization of their form no longer
functions
and they're in pain or they're suffering
or something is wrong but most people
and almost all life one of the core
aspects of life is the desire and the
will to fight to live
so when i see a chaotic destructive
force breaking things i see that as
inherently bad
because it defies the function of what
life does right
not necessarily a uh not at all i think
a christian framework any capacity
but certainly much more in alignment
with with the structure of order
creation and protection sometimes you
need destruction because too much
creation can lead to cancer too many
cells producing so you need cells to
apoptosis and destroy themselves
sometimes you need like neutral not not
creation or destruction but a balance
where the cell is just in in not
stagnation but in in synthesis or in
so there is like a neutral aspect to
to reality i think that we're we're
missing i think it's by design too
you could you could theoretically argue
that uh the critical theorists the woke
are actually an extremely harsh version
of order
where i recognize sometimes destruction
is is necessary if it serves the greater
you know the greater creation
unfortunately it is as we believe it now
in order for there to be negative
entropy there has to be greater entropy
created along along the way
however if you look at the woke and you
look at authoritarianism eventually
they are so rigid it's like creating a
giant
tower that goes up in a straight
vertical line it collapses
so in the short term you may say if the
woke had their way they would create a
rigid power structure which is very
orderly
those who take the power are in charge
and they can control systems that way
obviously the communists in in the
soviet union
had structure and order but it was so
rigid
and it was so straight up that
eventually you knock out one one you
know one blocking
the whole thing falls down so you need a
robust structure
ultimately i view woke left communist
social etc in the long term
as a destructive path it's like watching
someone build a bridge to nowhere where
eventually just crumbles and falls to
the ground
and it's destruction and they're
actively fighting against us
who are trying to build and prove and so
they're creating a system that's
susceptible to destruction because it's
brittle
from its uh extension but it does
destroy it
as a result of the falling bridge will
destroy that which it lands upon
sure they also are actively stripping
organizations and structures
to build their broken system which is
why
i view it more like an uh
what's the right way to put it there
there are people who are taking
resources
and building something nonsensical that
will eventually
destroy the system parasitic whatever
call it what you want i think that
jordan peterson has definitely
spoken to this because he talks about
the negative ramifications of having too
much
order and the negative ramifications of
having too much chaos
so when you get to the level of
authoritarianism you have too much
order but when you get to the level of
post-modernism when you can't even agree
on the definition of the word that
you're using to discuss these ideas
that is too much chaos so as far as
you're concerned
what fire yeah it's fire oh how's that
it's fire it's consuming resources and
control okay okay so not parasitic it's
like burning
okay but yeah so it like these ideas are
so disorganized and unstructured
this is the negative manifest
manifestation of chaos
and the negative manifestation of order
in both
wrapped into this nice little package of
wokeness this critical theory and i'm
not sure what their
end goal is here but i think hear me out
about this theory
let me know what you think i think that
religion and god
worked for a long time but now it's to
the point where it doesn't make sense to
a lot of people it's hard to measure we
can't really measure it
so people are looking for a unifying
theory
i think collective consciousness is real
but we don't have the tools to measure
it
yet by design because we're still in the
age of combustion so these people that
have kept us on copper and oil
have inadvertently disallowed us to
measure
like femtosecond vibrations of plasma
fields
so we can't see our magnetic fields
interacting we don't have the tools to
measure
how do you know about that um well if
you study some research
yeah you can study like vibrations of of
surface plasmon and you can see
light interacting with plasma and like
that seems like consciousness
no one's stopping you yeah but it's not
mainstream and that's a problem because
it could have been in the 30s when tesla
was working on it but the
the oil companies and the copper they
wanted to suppress that
this is that you're blaming someone else
for what you should be doing i think the
the in the the unexpected result is this
uprising of a new religion
because we've suppressed what is
actually real
i i disagree um i don't know what's
actually real
other than what we think we know as
humans i love this the story about what
humans used to think the brain was made
of based on the current science of the
time
like steam pressure now we believe
brains are more like computers because
we've invented computers
maybe we're getting closer maybe we're
not maybe eventually we'll think it's
magnetic plasma or something
but what we're seeing the rise of a
religion
because they were raised without that
religion they were raised without that
moral framework
and they're actively being converted i
look at you know i think maybe a really
good way to explain it is
is a prion disease or prion how we
pronounce it are you familiar with what
that is
yeah prion disease so basically we have
a structure
of self-replicating proteins that is our
system
and woke our malformed proteins that
when they come into contact with healthy
proteins
malformed them these proteins can't work
in the body and eventually lead to the
body's
death and destruction so uh i think what
was it mad cow disease was that
their brain disease eventually your
brain stops working and then you die
because the proteins aren't connecting
anymore properly
so malfunction let's get to that what is
malfunctioning because
i i mean that's something in terms of
getting back to hegel and just is there
objective truth or not
and for people to be making objective
truth statements that
it's contradictory for you to say
there's no such thing as as absolutes
but that
in and of itself is an absolute
statement right so i think that again
we find ourselves you know i like the
movie as a surfer 180 degrees south
where the
patagonia founders that are into surfing
and climbing and all that they
at one point in the movie say that you
know you want to be progressive
well at some point if you're going the
wrong way it's progressive to turn
around and go 180 degrees the other
direction
and i think in terms of our ability as a
civilization i like how oz guinness
calls we're living in a cut flower
society
where we're enjoying so much of the
fruits of western civilization and a lot
of ideas that come from athens that come
from greece people for thousands of
years have been developing ways to
reason
you know empiricism the scientific
method so
we see a lot of yard signs in seattle
that say science is real
okay what is science and what is real
science how do we actually do that
and in our case you know in terms of
applying uh
to all these issues just trying to think
clearly and think well
um about in our case how do you do
mental health work but
even these bigger questions of what's
true
if um i liked i heard one you were
talking about how there was something
about where like
um i don't know if there's a proton or
electron like that's that was
orbiting a vacuum yeah yeah so it was uh
uh
it was a trapped in uh in a circuit with
no nucleus
and it exhibited the chemical properties
of what it normally would with a single
electron in orbit
and when they injected more electrons
into it it exhibited the chemical
properties
of the appropriate atom with no nucleus
yeah so that's i mean that's it seems
like that's kind of what's going on
right now is that
as grace was saying earlier that you
know you can't just
remove this particular project without
being clear on what you're going to put
in its place and i would just hope that
we can just
take a deep breath and look at some of
the skills that our brothers and sisters
have developed over a long period of
time in terms of
just doing dialogue better doing science
better
because that's something we've seen the
american psychological association
association and others are out of their
lane
they're dealing with things that are
philosophical ontological that are not
empirical and that are that's that's
messing things up and we just need some
some honesty
and some some carefulness around the way
that we approach things
and i'd love to you know continue
conversations around things like
you know what what really is at the root
of these questions of what is true
but i think that you know fundamentally
we all share the values of wanting to
love people
and in our case we've just seen in a
particular way in which
uh loving people depends on truth
right and and that matters you know yeah
i you know a lot of what we see with the
woke is comforting lies
yeah they'll they'll tell you something
they'll make you feel good but will
destroy everything
and maybe it maybe it's a it's a lack of
uh
i guess foresight a lack of perspective
or vision or understanding
it's it's uh i'll give you a really
simple and uh
physical example real world example
someone posted on facebook earlier about
uh you know gun control no one's gonna
take away your guns blah blah blah and i
was like here's a list of the guns of
mine that are already being banned
like they're already banned in most
places and then they just come out with
memes like their knowledge is based on
memes they think they're helping
but they're angry there's no
conversation i can tell you outright
m1a banned maryland why well they
already took my gun away
you got you can't have it here in
maryland there are people who genuinely
believe
false things and because of that want to
build in the wrong direction which would
ultimately cause pain and suffering to a
lot of people
but when you're arrogant and you just
i guess egotistical maybe a lack of true
philosophical understanding
you're willing to burn down the entire
system for the sake of claiming you're
right it's
it's a problem humans have i suppose i
think um a lot of critical theorists
disagree with the scientific method have
issues with it and
something about that that's interesting
they call it the scientific method but
it's just one aspect of science
it's you could call it the floorbow
method you could call it like dark
method or whatever
it's it's a method of measuring
something over and over and over again
to make sure that it continues to happen
and then you can say okay fine that is
real and if you if
if it doesn't happen over and over again
then you say it's not real but a problem
with reality is sometimes things happen
and they don't happen over and over
again because they're happening for
reasons we don't understand or can't
measure
and so the scientific method is flawed
and it's it's saying
people are taking issue with that they
just don't have another type of science
yet to explain why someone might be born
with male genitalia but feel like
the gender is female but but it's flawed
in the sense that we're imperfect but
the fact that you recognize its flawed
in science recognize its limitations
means
it serves its purpose humility yeah it's
epistemic humility it's not arrogance
it's not you may not challenge
like please keep challenging it's quite
simple it's um
uh what's what's the saying those who
are uh
who are smart are so full of doubt you
know and the ignorant are so sure of
themselves something that if
something like that who wrote that was
it
but uh that that's the issue is that i
can simply say
when it comes to issues of universal
healthcare versus private healthcare
well i don't i don't know i don't have
the answers i'd love to look over the
data and figure out a plan to move
forward
but then you end up with zealots who say
the answer is clearly
one done if you don't want it you're bad
and i will fight you so that was
bertrand russell he said the whole
problem with the world is that fools and
fanatics are always
so certain of themselves and whys are
people so full of doubts
100 percent like the wiser you get the
more you're like oh i'm probably not
right
call me on this yeah the people uh i
look at this way
you've got five doors in front of you
four of them lead to sweet sweet freedom
one of them leads to a lion cage well
i feel the door give a little knock
then i'm finally on door number four i
hear oh my okay that that's nothing or
i'm sorry it should be
four of them lead to lions cages one to
freedom and so i just like bang bang
bang
and then i hear the roar bang my bang
here finally i bang on one i hear
nothing
i look down look under the crack of the
door i see some light and i'm like i
think that one's door to freedom
i don't know for sure but let's take a
peek i open it i see sunlight i say all
right
it's my best guess makes sense i
gathered evidence and i moved quickly
and then i bring the people behind me
with me to freedom
but too many people are like i don't
care number one
you know my politicians said door number
one is the right door and they open and
the line jumps out
then they claim it's your fault it's
it's see the system is broken there's
lions in this room
well well you let the lion in so
i think where we're getting to though is
so rationalism
has clearly failed you know like we
can't we can't just with our brains in
which our with our senses completely
comprehend
reality and then i i think empiricism
also has its limits right because
empiricism can only
still observe what exists in the natural
realm
and then we have all this other
knowledge that is true that is a part of
us like the transcendent like why
do we love what is beautiful why do we
want what is good
why do we seek the truth and all like
science doesn't
talk about that so these are like the
ultimate things that everyone is
answering and everyone has arrived at
even if it's just sort of an agnostic i
don't know no one knows like that is
still the framework
out of which you're operating and so
what i see happening also with this
critical social justice movement
is that they've actually arrived at a
transcendent version of science
they're saying that the you know the
classic you know textbook definition of
science
didn't isn't good because there's all
these other knowledges and they use that
word knowledge is plural
that we need to be observing we need we
need to be carefully
you know listening to because those
views have been pushed out to the margin
and in a way i'm like i think you're
right
and it's not it's not that people's
individual kind of standpoint
epistemology
is is going to get us to all the answers
you know that that's that's a fallacious
way of thinking
but there is the sense in which we need
something that also transcends the
empirical like
rationalism it enough is not enough
empiricism is not enough
there's more knowledge that is so true
to reality and to our understanding of
our self in reality that science doesn't
touch
this is why i say i i don't think that
the the left the woke
are acting in any sense of good faith i
was watching a uh documentary about air
conditioning and they said that our
thing was about skyscrapers
we couldn't build above like eight
stories because the accumulation of heat
as it rose made the upper floors
unbearable
until we invented uh window unit air
conditioners
then we put them in the windows and we
could filter the heat out of the
building and keep the building cool then
we could start building higher and
higher and higher
and then they mentioned that there were
actually ancient tribes
that already understood the principle of
pulling heat from the bottom and pushing
it out the sides
so that the upper levels of their
structures could be warmer or they could
remove the heat from the building to
keep the house keep their huts cooler
and these these tribes learn how to do
it by watching ants
there are ant hills in i think it's in
africa somewhere
where they grow these big towers that
pull heat
out of the the ant colony and then
funnel them out in different directions
understanding that principle by watching
nature these ancient tribes were able to
build
and utilize it to keep their their you
know houses cool
and we as you know eurocentric settlers
in the united states
didn't understand that technology so now
we're actually building skyscrapers that
follow more of these principles
because it's very very energy effective
and allows us to build without needing
massive amounts of air conditioning
you still got to pump water and air up
and stuff like that so
i see that and i say that's true there
it's very obvious that if we
paid more attention to other cultures
developments that's why
the actual diversity in the true sense
is good this is diversity of world
view that's not what we're getting from
the diversity inclusivity and equity
crowd yep they're looking for
homogeneity
they want everyone to conform to one way
of thinking
which is anti-objective no no we're
looking for objective truth
we have blind spots we find better
technology we
you know people often look at like how
did they move these big stones to build
these pyramids like they couldn't have
done it without a machine
and then some guy is like actually you
can use some wood there's a really
amazing video where this guy moved like
a two ton
a slab by hammering wood under it
digging a hole and then teetering it
back and forth until it flipped
and he's like you just got to keep doing
it you can move using its own weight and
counterbalance
and he was like so you don't need
gigantic machines to do it
there's also another video with like how
did the how did they split these rocks
so perfectly
and then a guy just like takes a an axe
and he hits it along the edge
and then the rock just splits it's like
there are techniques
that we might not know about or how
about was didn't didn't like ancient
greece or rome have like
cement that could dry under water yeah
and we're still like man how do they do
that
so but we understand that so what
happens is they exploit that
to the to the layman they hear this idea
did you know that
these ancient tribes already knew how to
do this
man if only the white man paid attention
and from that they go yeah why why don't
we do that
exploit that problem that is plainly
visible and then give them a solution
and they believe it well it's because
white people are racist and they
disregard
the true discoveries of other cultures
wow
and now they believe it now you've
indoctrinated and you begin converting
that protein into a malformed protein
where they no longer believe science is
real
but i tell you this if people live in a
broken world where there's no truth
they're extremely easy to control
and that's probably the the the end goal
in my opinion
right a group of subservient individuals
who will give you what you want
and you can exploit them no that's why i
think of it as management theory it's
really
pretty crass you know it's it's not it
you know whereas most
frameworks by which we would have a
conception of reality
are about establishing sort of a
meta-narrative right like
okay who are you what is the world how
do you relate to the world how do you
relate to other people
um this one is really just about
managing people
it's about it's about managing people
into categories by which we can easily
identify each other
and about having people mistrust whether
they can really know or how they know
so that the the knowledge is really
coming from a like a gnostic place it's
it's reserved to a few
uh on any given topic it's amazing i was
thinking the metaphor
of like if you're playing a video game
and you have like a a
multitude of characters to choose from
you have an archer you have a rogue you
have a warrior
and you get to pick your your party of
four people these
these critical theorists will pick four
archers
because they that's what they want they
want people that believe the same thing
and act the same way but then they'll
get skins
just like cosmetic skins of difference
they'll have one archer will look like a
woman
one archer will look like a black guy
one archer will look like a white guy
and then but the problem is it's not
real diversity they look different
but it's for archers you need different
people with different world views and
that's a very different type of
diversity
dude ranged dps you're seriously going
to go on a raid with nothing but range
deep now you got to go okay
and a healer at the start and then you
can talk about which range dp's are
going for
here's what they look like wear whatever
skin you want to wear
yeah i mean you know most people want
like the legit armor set
but you know end game characters end up
looking really funky because the best
armors don't usually go together
though i think you know a lot of games
started making that better like okay
fine
the tier three endgame armor is going to
be better so look if you want to go on a
raid and you want to have like a mage
you know he's a little squishy
but he's got some good ranged dps and
then you want to get a hunter because he
got the pet
you know you can't just go in with five
tanks
although i've seen videos of people
trying to do it and it's hilarious
it is and that's like critical theory
man you need a healer no
exactly they're claiming it's diversity
because it's like well we've got a rogue
who's uh spec for stealth we've got a
rogue who's backed for combat like no no
well it's cosmetic this rogue has a
black skin this rogue is a female this
rogue has white
yellow hair and they consider that
diversity but you can't right that's the
worst
that's a really good idea for a video we
should make where we we go on a world of
warcraft dungeon
and we just have like a white rogue a
black rogue
a lady rogue and alpha you know whatever
and we're like we've got five different
races of rogue we're going to go in and
beat the boss a truly diverse party
you get crushed i mean if you're really
strong you can do it
but maybe but it's not optimal that's
the point is you need true diversity
doesn't matter what skin
they can all be skinned to look like a
black woman but if you have a warrior
a rogue a wizard you're gonna have a
much more balanced party
and the cosmetics is irrelevant but to
these people
it's not necessarily that's the problem
i wonder if people watching
all in in their entirety completely
understood all those references no way
no god
they were all like i have no idea yeah
a little lost yeah so in uh in in most
like uh rpg mmo games well he's i'm
mostly referring to world of warcraft
you have a team of five people and
they're a tank
is a reference to a character that can
take a lot of damage
they don't give a lot of damage a healer
that one's obvious
and then dps means damage per second so
you have people who can fire arrows or
magic spells
and then you have rogues in warcraft who
are up close
slicing and dicing and stuff if you want
to win
almost every single normal run will be
we need a diverse team right we need
these different kinds of characters
diverse and capacity and in
functionality and function
instead ian makes a really good point
that would be hilarious to watch
like five priests trying to you know win
a dungeon and it's like well like peace
priests can do damage if they're spec
shadow but
you're not gonna have it like it's not
gonna work all that well like the
it's interesting games are designed this
way to require diversity of player
function interesting
yeah the real world the real world is
similar like art imitates life
it's true well remember nicole hannah
jones talking about how
you can be politically black and right
be politically white
even though you're actually black this
kind of superficial
well no that's that's in critical theory
all identities are politicized
your your identity is only your
political identity which is why they
could treat you one way
with thinking if he's a white man and
one way thinking you as a mixed man
i do have to counter that that that
point though ian ah yes
world of warcraft has racial abilities
tell me more yo you're right
different races have difficulties so uh
void elf they can teleport
so you can have five rogues of different
races with different abilities
you're still not gonna that's meta
diversity yeah you're still not gonna
win
i mean you can you can try but yeah i
think if you had a team of five paladins
though you could because they're healers
tanks and dps
i feel excluded from this hegemonic
discourse i feel discriminated against
for sure
you haven't played a lot of warcraft no
oh no or just roleplaying my brother did
my brother did quite a bit yeah
dungeons and dragons and all that stuff
so that would be like what country are
you from but where were your ancestors
from
like depending on where your ancestors
were from would be your racial ability
but where you're from is like what class
you were
right i'm done with this metaphor it's
funny we've been exhausted i can't i
can't contribute anything
yeah i got nothing better well so i
guess uh man just what's the final final
leg of the story you guys uh got a bunch
of
you know anti-woke anti-sjw
fat dudes and fedoras with katanas to
like storm into the building and
the big fat feminists were chased out or
what no
we were uh we love all those people
we were just um yeah we we wanted to
continue having the conversation as long
as conversation was possible and
there came a point at which each of the
people who left
left on moral grounds saying that they
they wouldn't want to be a part of an
organization that is
white supremacist for instance so yeah
it was just sort of like okay
that's you know you're living according
to your moral beliefs and we disagree
with you you have these deeply held
commitments convictions whatever you
want to call it and
um yeah i think it you know
i i just think it took you guys longer
than it would take me
you know like but i get it and uh um if
it were me
and i was wearing an organization and
someone you know put an open letter i'd
be like bro door's right there
yeah like no beef like you don't i got
no obligation you got an obligation
well here's here's where it's tricky
because
employers know that employees
who are oriented towards this ideology
will
turn that into an attack on the
organization if there's any sense of i
was wrongfully terminated
or i was i was shoved out because of my
beliefs
you know so honestly i think the
principled approach that we took
is the only approach if you don't want
your organization if you don't want to i
disagree a pyrrhic victory for instance
there's like okay you won but like
now you're in litigation if if uh
if if i had an employee say that they
wanted everyone to
name their gender pronouns i would pull
them aside and say
i cannot allow you to be homophobic or
transphobic and force people to out
themselves
that's kind of what we said you need
yeah you can't and if you do that again
then i'm gonna have to ask you to leave
for you know discrimination no and we
did it with research we said hey look
here's what the actual research says i
put together like a 14-page paper on
gender identity
and and it was all the research like
cited throughout the paper
like actual peer-reviewed you know
controlled
real research um and and it was
basically like
hey this is actually not best practice
this this is this can be damaging to
people in dysphoric conditions to be
asked to name their gender identity into
a space full of strangers by the way
and so what was really disheartening
though is because
this has more of a religious nature to
it that this person is like
that's all good these are probably a
bunch of studies written by white guys
anyway
they don't understand i'm the one with a
critical consciousness and i'm
i'm an ally for these people it's my job
to make sure they're not harmed and i
can see you have no
interest in understanding things from
their perspective therefore you are
transphobic i still have my deeply held
convictions and i'm going to act on
those
and so it's at that point you're like
we're really at an impasse you know
yeah um but that's what that's what
happens when you when you erode the
foundations of how do we arrive at what
is true normally we've had our
scientific method right it's like i'm
showing you all the studies i'm showing
you what they say this is the best
research we have to date
and like that is irrelevant this is the
the pitfall of
true liberalism yep when we say you
can't discriminate on the basis of race
gender national origin religion
okay now define discriminate so i was uh
i mentioned this in a segment a couple
days ago about coca-cola doing these
woke trainings
and i was like they want to have these
trainings where they start talking about
whiteness
all right if i were there i would
immediately file a complaint saying
they're trying to have a white
supremacist meeting
how do you define white supremacists
well it doesn't matter so my argument
would be
to make minority individuals go into a
room to be taught about white people
is discriminatory because they don't
have meetings about black people or
asian people
only white people that's true so i told
them that you know it's racist i would i
would say absolutely none of that
if they said we want to do pronouns i
would say this is
harassment of the lgbtq employees
who don't want to out themselves and if
you bring it up again you're gone
people don't do this only the woke do
this
so long as only the woke are exploiting
that system it will go in their
direction but like i said it's a problem
of
liberalism in that we created the civil
rights act to protect people
from there there is just a it is a sieve
it is just holes to leak through because
no matter what you do you are
discriminating period and they know that
and they exploit that
yeah and we one quick add-on to that too
is just that
in terms of the spirit of what you want
to actually see happen there we we ended
up into a place where it's like we don't
want to just
play games and use the same rules that
you have and apply them back to you to
try to
you know in some cases show you that we
can't live this way
um but you know in terms of the the
space where you want to be inclusive the
whole point is we have these tools that
are meant for everybody to be able to
benefit from
and how can we make people feel like
they can come and be a part of that
um so there are solutions and that was
the the effort is how
can we be informed and get to a place
where we don't just
play a game back and forth with a use of
language but to actually
make progress in the world there are
solutions and for us in that one
particular case it's like why don't we
just
give put the power in the hands of that
individual and just say
you know we're going to go around and as
part of our guidelines that include all
the normal stuff of just
you know being respectful and
everything you'd want to do in civil
conversation these people
um in sharing uh at the beginning to get
to know each other why don't you just
invite them just to share how you'd like
to be referred to in the space
because that doesn't make anybody say a
pronoun and then that if somebody
is still not satisfying is what we
learned you're not satisfying
what the goal was again was to bring
that
gender identity category explicitly into
the space
as a way of reflecting back to those
people that they're seen
so it still wouldn't satisfy it yeah so
what you guys found was that there is
not a compromise there
there's nothing you can do to make it so
that you are happy
and feel that you're serving your own
moral standard
and that they're happy and you're giving
them what they're looking for
right there's just no common ground and
i think they make it that way on purpose
right that's the reason they keep their
definition so loose
and easy and they change it on you in
the middle of an argument
and you were talking about this before
the show the concept of making them play
by their own rules
holding them to their own standards
exactly hold them to their own rules
hold them to their own standards and i
think that's the only way to fight back
against this
this is in the rules for radicals this
is in the book that they follow whether
they know it or not
right if someone said i want everyone to
say the gender pronouns i'd be like
right me exactly are you trying to force
people to out themselves why are you a
white supremacist who wants to
physically harm them so you want them to
reveal
that's insane there you go how dare you
bring that into my my office
we protect our lgbt employees and their
right to privacy
well seriously that's what i did i see
it's like a kind of
linguistic credentialism they have where
they have this whole
jargon that they use and that they
employ against people and most people
just feel like overwhelmed by like i i
don't know what i'm even being accused
of i don't know what all these
heteronormativity
phrases are what are you talking about
um but i did
i did learn enough to know that when i
was told
i wasn't allowed to speak on a certain
topic because i'm straight
i said well wait a minute how do you
know i'm straight just because i'm
married to a man
you know it's like within your own
within your own framework
you know like i could be any i could be
any sexual identity any gender identity
right now
based on their own framework you'd be a
dog i'm not i'm not exaggerating right
so
this is an uh a freedom tunes cartoon
are you guys familiar with freedom tunes
sheamus how's it going buddy uh he made
one where he's talking about gender and
he said
the arguments about critical gender
theory is that men and women
are on a spectrum you know it's it's a
gender spectrum
for instance some men um are infertile
so reproduction or the production of
sperm doesn't make them a man
some men might lose their privates in an
accident they're still men
and he said right like what
differentiates a dog from a person
a person walks on two legs okay well
some dogs walk on two legs does that
mean a dog could be a person well but
humans use toilets and he said yeah well
uh dogs don't and some humans in
california also don't
so the issue is there it's true
so the the issue is they deconstruct
concepts to make excuse for why certain
ideas exist
that that logic right there shows
they'll exploit anything to claim it was
a violation
and they'll use it to gain power right
but again you can use that against them
you know if you're just deconstructing
my you know gender anything any societal
norm
i can deconstruct your theory i can
deconstruct your deconstruction if
everything is a social construct
why does this stand i just i just say
like uh discussions of race are banned
at this company
it's because we don't want any
harassment so all discussions of race
gender national origin religion you
can't do it don't talk about it
have a nice day and that's nice that
you're in control
how do we how do we talk about
discrimination well you can talk to your
boss
but if you want to go and harass are you
saying you want to you want to harass
employees
because if you want to harass our
employees i'm sorry that's harm and
people here don't feel safe around you
that's that's that's that's the game you
know and i suppose the problem is that's
what they want
they pull you down into the fray so that
you use it you're playing by their rules
they've won
their rules they walk away laughing
saying thank you for adopting my rules
thank you for adopting my my world view
and my way of life that's exactly what
we wanted in the first place
oh intolerance so the alligator wants
you
yeah to come underwater and fight it
with intention so you're thinking all
right i'll drag you
under water and he's like that's all i
ever wanted yeah
but who i mean that's the thing though
is there are people that are that
self-aware that are doing that but just
again right now trying to have the
victim villain mindset and we're trying
to speak
to people we love and care about and you
know in a way that
can point it out and uh have a good
dialogue to where you can be
um i love the concept of the noble
adversary
and how in philosophy it's so helpful to
have somebody that might be completely
on the other side of an issue but as
long as
truth is on the throne then you both can
be
very helpful to one another and i love
that question is just how
how can truth contradict you and is
truth on the throne
in your life what if they don't believe
in truth
well then you don't have to listen to
anything they say they can say nothing
objectively that's that could
what happens when they're the dominant
political party and they control the
house the senate the presidency and
they're passing laws based on the stuff
that's the problem yep so that that the
issue i see is that
there are many people who think that
these people want to have a dialogue
that these people are trying to improve
things i don't think fire is
evil i think the person who set the fire
is the person who's watching it and
laughing and
seeing it destroy the building but you
don't argue with fire
it's just spreading and destroying you
put the fire out immediately
and there are some circumstances where
you can use fire to prevent the spread
of fire controlled burn in a field for
instance
you got to be careful you got to do it
right typically we just spray water on
things though
which means if you want to maintain your
principles you can't
in the end in my opinion use you know
the rules for radicals i suppose because
then you're just spreading fire along
with it so
i suppose though controlled burn could
work in the end though
perhaps there's a surgical approach to
using a controlled burn in certain
settings where it must be done
and then overall we need to keep
spraying water on the fire
fire also can keep you alive in the
right circumstances like a controlled
bonfire you can cook it can keep you
warm but
that's like critical race theory has
some value or critical theory
in that it questions power structures
and we were born into an imperialist
power structure it's worth questioning
but when it gets out of control and then
it
it loses its own tolerance and can't has
problems with
with upending itself when it's it sees
its own flaws that's the the wildfire
that's dangerous
and that's what and you can see i mean
you guys are dealing with that yeah
we'll have critical theory that you
can't critique
right let's go to super chats oh yeah we
uh we chill on this friday night
everybody
so uh make sure you go to timcast.com
become sign up to become a member we got
a bunch of really cool stuff coming we
actually are building this auction
system
which means we're gonna it's not just
about auctioning off you know weekly
tickets to the to the space to come hang
out for our friday night events
but we're actually going to be able to
like have signed t-shirts and
you know other weird stuff yeah t-shirts
mugs pillows
the original our pillow i should we
should auction that off that's a good
one
see how much we can get for so the
original our pillow is a burlap sack
full of styrofoam packing peanuts in
fact i will get it now yeah it's that
it's the communist
version of my pillow because you know
have you guys ever used a my pillow
we have given one to my dad so a present
it's like it's it's it's got a bunch of
basically like foam
memory foam bits inside he really likes
it yeah so we decided you know what
we'll we'll cut the corners we'll get a
burlap sack we'll throw a pack of
peanuts
we should wash this thing okay maybe no
no one's
but we'll auction that off for sure and
then these these silly trinkets will
help fund more work and yeah
we're hiring some journalists so let's
say some super chats my friends you must
give a little tap that like button it
really does help out let's read what we
got here
ib drago says 1984 is now and red dawn
isn't far behind just saying
yikes joey meldeman says hey tim since
google is censoring search results
i recommend using brave browser it's
powered by the bat cryptocurrency is
safe secure and pays you in bat for
viewing ads when when
i we use brave we do and whenever we
pull up articles you can see the little
brave icon
we almost exclusively use brave
sometimes we need other browsers for
pulling something up
we'll use brave for everything because
brave is awesome and the bat token is
great
all right let's see
euphoric break says i've been keto eight
years now i turn
50 next week and i am on no
pharmaceutical drugs just eat real food
hey there you go a super chip based on
our sponsor of the day
check out the link in the description
below nice josh l says hey all
how come people talk in chat in a way
they never would to another person in
real life
i consistently see people say crap that
i know they'd never say to another
person face to face
it's really interesting isn't it so um
who was it that
made that quote mike tyson made the
quote that being online has made people
comfortable with
saying things that would get them
consequences in the real life yeah
punching the face
yeah okay yeah i wasn't going to say
that we don't say that here is that real
or is that
debunked i think that's real is it yeah
i saw it the other day i was like yep
it's true
you see this guy key mark is trying to
get me whoa but you're not gonna get me
but i'm gonna rig your super chat anyway
i love it where's bucko
can you let him know michael malus's
amazing new book the anarchist handbook
is now for sale on amazon for 19
he will love it buckle would love that
bucko went feral
yeah he did so we started letting him go
outside and then he killed
he's a cat okay he killed he killed a
rabbit
and was dr just carrying the body of the
rabbit around like very proud that he
killed it
and then we saw him uh chewing on it and
i was like oh that's to be expected
and then after the show a couple nights
ago i went downstairs
and he was eating it on the floor in the
in the in the kitchen
it has since been buried he has he
severed its head and was chewing on its
spine
we should have done it it was brutal it
was like metal
yeah it was like the most metal thing
buckle's ever done he also eats
mealworms
super excited we got a new chicken yeah
yeah dorothy stuff
dorky she's a what is it a barred rock
bart plymouth bard rock
oh you highlighted her on instagram no
was that wasn't dorothy no that's
margaret i didn't know you got a new
chicken
yeah so some somebody not too far away
said that the chicken was an escape
artist
and that they had to like they couldn't
keep it because it was going to get out
and get eaten
and i was like well we've got this
fortified coop and she's currently
laying eggs
and it was funny because i was like i
wonder what's going to happen because
our chickens have never been around
another chicken before
we put her in and the chickens did
literally nothing like
no reaction at all interesting to see
once they start all laying eggs is when
they really develop their pecking order
and just that's what we found with our
chickens well
uh dorothy is already laying uh-huh so
we bought it might be the queen
she's the queen yeah queen dorothy yep
dorothy
we're pretending like she's related to
vanessa big old girl yeah they are
related
whoa is this true red state bound says
space force lieutenant colonel matthew
lohmeier removed after facebook post
announcing marxism look this
up david palmer says any charities you
guys trust i'm looking to donate but
want my money spent well
um well one thing you can definitely do
if you want to contribute
not all charities are tax deductible
which means you may as well contribute
to something that is going to do great
work like going to timcast.com and
becoming
a member i'm kidding but definitely do
that too uh any charities you guys
recommend
find me on twitter yes they have a good
one
so yours yeah absolutely
doobie mcnasty says the only pronoun we
all need to share is human
what is your pronoun human humor i am
human
uh tex avery says as a trans person i
have disagree with gender pronoun woke
nonsense people have a right to talk
about you however they want
there you go it's true it's going
against the grain
yeah daddy day 71 says tim wanted to
provide some clarity for your 4pm video
you can become a commissioned officer
without having a college degree i know
many who have become
limited duty officers or chief warrant
officers interesting
the median says israel will not fall
even if they take down their wall and if
russia iran egypt and turkey all attack
israel together
israel has been around longer than the
u.s and will be here after
favorite water-based mammal oh um
that was the segway yeah anybody would
you got it
platypus i mean because come on what is
it is that a water-based amount
it is yeah that's a mammal that lays
eggs yeah what is it under water
well it's amphibious yeah yeah i mine is
hippos
water-based hippos are awesome yeah
dolphins too though because they protect
surfers from sharks
there you go i don't think i have one no
i could just say a random
animal i guess capybara walrus oh yeah
oh yeah i mean i guess capibara they're
not water-based but they love
water awesome i think they're the
friendliest animal right they are yeah
yeah like all the other animals just
like hang out with them yeah and and
nobody wants to like eat them for some
reason it's weird
they're so friendly like the predators
are like nah you're cool dude
that's right what is it about them
what's the treat
they're super chill there's videos of
them like sitting in hot springs and
their eyes are like half clothes like
the stoners of nature yeah
i love them nobody wants to eat them i
guess they're so cute maybe they taste
bad they got a bunch of lice that's what
i heard
oh really that's gross not good actually
kind of gross
lucas parata says great guests question
for them did they approach the issue
from a spiritual perspective
i feel these ideologies can't be brought
into the light without a spiritual
approach
that's a great question well our
staff was of diverse religious and
spiritual backgrounds
so that was something to take into
account yeah and i would say that
that also it was the idea of personal
versus professional
came to light in terms of just how often
times um
that the organized world views are
quickly
called out but people are not aware of
just the fact that we all have a world
view and that again
people are out of their lane when you're
trying to do you know science or have
empirical conversations around
these types of things we we all need to
just be honest about that fact so that
is something that we laid early on with
the groundwork was
we all operate on faith at some level
especially about the ultimate things
yeah true kailand riley says tim why do
you still bother using newsguard
they gave cnn an objectivity rating of
eight out of ten they gave the daily
wire a three out of ten
that would be like giving ian a sanity
rating of eight out of ten and you a
three out of ten
rude i'm a wizard because it is a
wizard it's a bias check so when people
are like tim's fake news i'd be like
all my sources are certified by
newsguard and they gave cnn an 8 out of
10 and daily wire three out of ten
so if you don't trust them i don't know
who i'm supposed to trust
it was funny there was like some fake
report that claimed to me
and like it included me in a list of
people spreading election misinformation
and i was like what what did i say about
the election like like seriously tell me
all of the articles i use on everything
are certified by newsguard period
so that's really a tech on newsguard and
if newsrt doesn't take issue with it you
know
whatever so they're microsoft funding i
guess and uh
i think they're super biased they give
media matters like a 90 out of 10 like
like 90 out of 100. like an organization
that literally just puts out fake news
and conspiracies
oh yeah they're credible sure
drew richmond says tim crucial
conversations is a great book
gnc's approach to their employees is cc
in action
i used it myself when i did mediation
between truant teens and parents
it helped me in my life too ian you
would love it
interesting there you go gotta
oh cool awesome thank you guys joe no
uh noveratti says tim can you shout out
rimfire apparel on facebook we're a
family owned second amendment apparel
startup
out of new jersey shout out to rimfire
apparel very cool thank you for the
super chat
mountain man chucks has any thoughts on
alexander
dugan fourth political theory shout out
to jack murphy interviewing michael
millerman and dugan himself oh any
thoughts i saw mike millerman tweeting
about dugan recently
but i'm not well informed i don't know
anything yeah i don't really
know that name
sleepless in phoenix says long time
viewer and big phantom
can you give a friends link a shout out
it is help tony burns compete in formula
drift on gofundme
the a in fanned is actually meant to be
a you
go fand me censorship is getting crazy
it won't even let me put the word fund
in super chat but you literally put fund
in the super chat
afterwards so maybe you can't say
gofundme i guess
claymore says didn't they say great
leaders don't seek power
it is thrust upon thee or at least they
used to
yeah yeah that was that was how it was
supposed to be i guess
who whose quote is that oh i don't know
oh yeah
you look it up that's a shakespeare
quote is it yeah i think so sounds right
it's very weird there's a power
yeah devin stark says tim prions are
formed by eating brains
the proteins are correct for the
original brain but malformed for the one
eating them
i wonder uh what what that makes this
all a reference to
i think it's related to jefferson's
tyranny over the mind of man
oh yeah right just the this whole
philosophical movement is to control
people's thoughts or like freedom to
have thoughts you know it really is sort
of
management i mean if you're managing
people's speech and what they can read
you're kind of
saying you shouldn't think certain
things either definitely this
shakespeare quote was that some are born
great some achieve greatness and some
have greatness thrust upon them yeah
not the not that great leaders don't
seek power i don't know
i don't know where that comes from i
don't know i mean
you know donald trump uh the greatest
leader of all time
sought power what is power kidding by
the
way
power just authority i mean i don't it's
not just authority
that's the question that i think is
really important what's the difference
between power and authority
huh i think all legitimate power comes
from authority
power uh
power uh grants authority in a certain
sense but
disagree what do you mean i think that i
mean there can be illegitimate power
right
like somebody just wielding brute force
over another person and then there's
authority which gives a person the due
right to have
power in a situation you know think
about a parent and a child i don't think
authority is due right
well how do you define authority uh
hierarchical
command structure power okay so i'm not
defining authority that way
i'm defining you're saying like you're
defining authority as like the authority
on a subject like the
expert yeah the authority or the actual
author of a thing the actual creator of
a thing
so yes interesting so that you know
is where our founding documents come
from for instance yeah
that our rights are rooted in the
authority of a creator yeah
and that that creator is due the power
that we're
you know so recognizing
a soldier would be given a gun that
would be authority but the person who
took the gun
would be not authority but they would
they would also have power
so the power derived from right
illegitimate authority or yeah yeah
other means right so you can be a person
who has legitimate authority and
therefore your power is legitimate or
you can be a person who
has no authority and then therefore any
power you have is illegitimate
interesting yeah i think it's a kind of
a component of
this whole conversation because i do
think that critical theory since it's
built on assertions has no legitimate
authority and therefore all the power
that it's wields is illegitimate which
is why there's so much intimidation
involved
because there's nothing there there's
actually nothing there hollow yeah
don jet says woke baby children's book
my wife stumbled upon
scary-ish if you guys can find it you
should read it
it's short and worth it for its insanity
i'm pretty sure it's by ibram candy
i think it is baby yeah that sounds
right that guy's out of his mind
awoke baby but but he asked like i think
someone like ibram ex candy he's just
like a legit con artist you know what i
mean like that's my opinion on
what he is it's that saying something
like the root of what does it say the
root of racism is
in denialism or whatever the heartbeat
of racism is denial right
right like the dude's clearly a con like
conning people you know
in my opinion yeah oh are you going to
say i was saying it's very similar to
robin d'angelo's whole argument is if
you deny that you have white fragility
it's proof that
it's the same exact it's the same exact
kafka trap did he put x in his name
because of malcolm x
probably that's like clown makeup
pretty much yeah i don't know if that's
true i know it's not look it up he's got
his own birth name why did malcolm x
have an x in his name i don't know
because it's his name possibly just his
middle initial or the tenth person
king cringe says acting with integrity
within their moral framework seems like
a capitulation to abhorrent behavior
this can be applied to witch hunts lynch
mobs genocide
every zealot believes their actions are
for some greater good
yep that's a good point but would you
rather people believe things and not act
on them
i mean did you get on the right there's
there's a line
i remember when i was little i was in
school and i was walking down the
hallway and there's a big banner that
said stand up for what you believe in
and then i asked some i asked my teacher
i was like what if someone believes in
like
you know beating someone based on like
their race or their like who they love
and they're like well
i mean i was like should someone in the
class stand up if they like hate a
person
like based on their race or something
great question yeah there was a really
great point that was brought up on
tucker carlson's show when he was
talking about cancel culture
someone said um they talk about free
speech
and they were like tucker you don't
believe in free speech either if someone
came on your show and said something
racist you'd remove them from your show
it's like yes i would he's like exactly
so why are you mad that social media
companies and of course the argument is
bonk because the the issue isn't
necessarily that you know youtube
facebook or whatever are banning people
for being racist
it's that they're banning people who are
literally often on one side of political
political spectrum for highly dubious
reasons right but it's true though
uh carlson would absolutely boot someone
from his program for saying racist
things well it's a it's a great point
what you ask your teacher is should the
people who believe in atrocious things
stand up for those things
yes and that's why everyone should be
examining what their underlying
presuppositions
are about reality and be honest about
what those are
because everyone is making assumptions
about what's real what's true what's
right
and and you should act on them but if
you haven't ever examined what those are
that it could be something that
you know is not sound is not an
alignment with truth
are you familiar with the paradox of
intolerance who's that guy that they're
always citing who wrote that
i don't remember so they the left loves
this meme where it's like should we
tolerate intolerance and it's like
no because if you do eventually the
intolerant take over and i'm like that's
a really great reason why we shouldn't
tolerate you
so we shouldn't tolerate
authoritarianism in any aspect
be it fascism nazism communism socialism
whatever
yeah bye-bye y'all can go now what does
it mean to tolerate fascism well i don't
care if you have the ideas and you speak
them
but but if you are politically
organizing then i think we absolutely
should not tolerate
this woke insurgency because they're
authoritarians
um malcolm x the x stood it was a
response to reject slavery that's why i
put
x there um ibram x kendi his middle name
is zolani
xolani so i guess it's actually is his
initial
all right julie simone says sounds like
dunning-kruger effect a type of
cognitive bias where people believe
they're smarter and more capable than
they are
basically low ability people don't
possess the skills to recognize their
own incompetence
check it out i'm very familiar and you
know my favorite thing growing up was
when people would say when dumb people
would also use dunning-kruger
they would say well you're an example of
dunning-kruger and i'm like bro i'm the
one who's saying i'm not entirely sure
you're the one who's overly confident i
got no problem saying i don't know man
i'm trying my best
the other funny thing was i remember you
know i had these arguments about
religion stuff when i was younger
i would often hear like you need to have
an open mind
and i would be like now hold on just a
minute because that statement itself is
paradoxical
you're disagreeing with my view claiming
i'm the of the closed mind
why can't i just assert the same thing
of you and say you don't have an open
mind
it's a pointless statement yep
damon bauer says you should try to get
richard andrew grove on
he is a very knowledgeable person on
this he has been covering this
information on philosophical corruption
of reality in the origins of it
very interesting look him up you've
never heard that name
tyler fulkerson says big fans it's
occupy want to say how much the air
force has changed a lot since 2016.
extremism training was their last straw
was the last straw for me
getting out in august it's a bomber man
here we go excellion says just run all
druids tim he's right
jurors are pretty bad but bro druids can
be tanks healers
and dps that's a good way yeah that's
buster it's legit
man we always we're alive
they get stealth they get you know
stronger armor
they get resto and now they got moon kin
form they got owl like they get travel
for it man
they're so good jurors are the best in
work i just don't like playing
playing druids though okay yeet says oh
i forgot to say this is from my ethereum
classic winnings
i like how you refer to it as winnings
ah here we go john lee says
hey tim and wow you can run a full team
of druids and clear raids me and my
brother used to
used to run this i know i know and
theoretically you could probably do
paladins too but not nearly as good as
druids
not in d though druids aren't that tough
in d really
yeah they're more they're more like
priests
shane kerwood says totally with you guys
on the rpg metaphor
i understood every word and it's a
brilliant example okay laughing love
this show you guys are the absolute best
see i knew they're gonna be people who
hurt us using that and they're gonna be
laughing the whole time
although all the people talking about
druids were like actually oh gosh
you got us but they were right interface
moonfire drew it for life all right
youtube just jumped on us they always do
this
we get a bunch of super chats all at
once and then goes
james orenthal new uh uh new union is
how you pronounce it
leroy jenkins stop asian hate in 2021
silence is not violence
if you're still reading please consider
pre-ordering my pre-ordering michael
knowles new book speechless controlling
words
controlling minds they're everywhere the
smartest thing
i've ever seen in any marketing campaign
is making a meme where people go to
other people's channels to get them to
promote
michael knowles's book so smart i should
start doing that with
like we don't have any like strong merch
i guess our pillow
you'll sleep better on our pillow yeah
make sure to buy arc pillow yes
good communist pillow jack posix been
doing
william carlos says please this is my
third attempt so hi
i wrote a free book about exactly these
topics specifically about fallacies
biases and axioms i am a william carlos
on
minds love the show there you go
great lone wolf says man i love
ian no insinuations there just honest
brother you bring such a great element
to the table for example the uncommon
thoughts and angles of viewpoint
that's right the wolf is my spirit
animal it is it is funny to like imagine
someone playing warcraft and like
have five rogues and just have one who's
black ones who's white one is a woman
you need some diversity here yeah right
we can't we
can't beat this dungeon we need
diversity so so what do we need for this
dungeon well we need a black rug
we need a white rogue a female rogue a
black female rogue and an elf it's like
that's diversity enough for me
i had a vision that i was being attacked
by a an eagle
or some sort of hawk and a wolf dove out
of like the veil and
and it spun around and protected me from
the the bird spirit
okay speaking of the wolf being my
spirit you're an animal just wanted to
make it tofu poncho says good job bucko
tear it up yes
thanks and then no no no no no no hold
on hold on the cat yeah buckle killed a
baby rabbit we were like oh
big man you go to bb and then he comes
up the next day with a baby mouse
and we're like is that the best you can
do bro killing babies
that's sad yeah i'm just getting started
no he no it's like he's all proud of
himself
he like walks up like look what i did
and we're like dude really
okay you want us to be impressed by you
killing a baby rabbit
he starts eating it he's being trained
by the neighbor's cat he is it's very
hunters i have to defend bucko because
he thinks that tim is very bad at being
a cat
and he needs like really small little
meals to make him full and fill his
tummy so he's bringing tim these little
he's not bringing him to me he brought
him to the he
him and and herman the other cat brought
him to the the the
green room entrance which is like the
lower floor i wasn't down there
it was it was like andreas and and you
know it's like this is for anyone who's
here
you're welcome i think he was i don't
think he so a lot of people say that
cats will bring you dead animals because
they're trying to like hey you're bad at
hunting here let me show you
like here's how you here's what you do
no no he was parading it around proud of
himself
it was the first thing he had ever
killed like he was an indoor cat and we
got him little
we got him armor you know he's a vast
little bow on it
he brought to one door and then like the
next day he brought it to the other door
yeah he was like showing us yeah he's
very proud of himself and the other cat
who's an outside cat who lives outside
and hunts all the time and like just i
watched him one time
playing with the mouse and like swatting
it was brutal like he was teaching bucko
how to do all the stuff it's funny he
like follows him around and like watches
and then
so cute yeah that's great is this
keeping poop off the skate ramps
uh well he's never allowed anywhere near
the skate ramps okay but the cat doesn't
poop
you know no i remember killing the the
cult oh well the problem is we have
birds in the garage
because but we cleared out the roof
we're doing like clean up and remodeling
so now the problem is
there are these tiny little bugs and
every night
they reproduce about a million of them
i'm not even exaggerating like no joke
like a million
and so every morning in the garage no
joke the ground
is blanketed with like you'll see dots
all over the ground
and you it's like it was really funny so
i i pointed out
and i came over hosting they're like uh
just they thought it was dust
and so i took the uh the leaf blower and
i started blowing the floor and clearing
it and then you have a big clump a huge
clump
of dead bugs of like flies of some sort
weird
yeah so i'm wondering if like the
chickens can eat them because then what
we'll do is we'll just
it's free meal you know right i don't
know what they're eating to be like to
make more bugs they're certainly eating
something
the other bugs i guess wood
dude the other night i opened the door
after the show
and then all of a sudden no joke about a
thousand tiny bugs flew in my face and
so i pulled the door closed and i'm like
they're everywhere i started flying
around
and then i looked out i turned turn the
light on and it's just it was a cloud
it was like a horror movie i wonder if
those are locusts no is that the
beginning
absolutely not no these are tiny little
flies or cicadas rather oh so what we're
going to do
oh they got through my screen in my
window see i have to keep my windows
closed because they
they're smaller than the screen holes
they're tiny and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
get like 10 bug zappers
and we're going to create just like a
fortress and so we had a bug zapper last
year
and ian you got mad because yeah it was
just going like i felt inhumane
like inside and just let it roll it
sounded like a permanent
high-powered taser going off non-stop
and then ian was like why are we just
killing the bugs for the sake of killing
them and i'm like we're trying to get
the bugs off the porch
but it was like it's like you know
normal bug zapper
every few seconds you're like this one
was like
and when you could see the arcs and we
were like what is going on yeah that was
a fire hazard
from star wars yeah yeah exactly killing
bugs
no more unlimited bugs
all right what is this uh gg player says
want to clarify my chat from the other
night
when i went to parnell's website and it
said i could not find the ip that was
only when i used
your link oh it was the correct link i
double checked it
brian says tim and ian i'm running for
congress and i want your ideas to make
policies and give the people back the
power and wealth
um you know what i got it
if i ever run for office it'll be to
like abolish
everything solve it oh that's one way to
go
i'll be like we're going to start over
i'm pretty nuanced i want to get rid of
everything and then we'll just you know
one thing you could do is
at a local level create an app that lets
you allocate your local tax funds i love
that
yeah like with sliding bars so like
you'll slide up two percent
and everything else like drop down point
one percent and it's like tinder so
you'll see like
i want to build um a fountain on main
street and so you'll swipe right if you
want to add it to your list of things
that you want to apply tax money to and
then you can like
put your tax dollars and that is the
most right-wing thing i've ever heard
yeah libertarian on the way
yes that's awesome it's an interesting
position where it's like
you should still be forced to pay taxes
but you get to choose where they go
yeah it's like okay well then you're not
paying taxes because you're gonna be
like no roads no water no firefighters
no cops some of them
will be grayed out at like five so the
police you'll have to pay at least like
six percent
fire department will be at four percent
and you hat so there's minimums for some
oh interesting i love it i think it's
great
professor enigma says i believe the
future of gaming will be currency
in-game as an altcoin
people can invest in the coin and
increase the value of items in-game
for a long time in world of warcraft
gold
had real world value and there were i
can't remember we were talking about we
were talking about like um maybe like
cuba or venezuela they world of warcraft
gold in their online accounts
they would keep because it actually had
value to americans venezuela
venezuela so they would actually rather
hold world of warcraft gold because it
was
less risky than the venezuelan currency
wow
crazy yup
no name says am i god i'm sorry but
you're not no
yeah sorry i think you are bad news what
if what if no name is
oh you're a finger like god's just like
sitting back in his chair this eyes have
closed watching the show and he's like
oh my god and we're like no and he goes
[Laughter]
i could see it the real mr pink says
yotim love the show what you're doing
you are truly on the front lines of the
culture war sent you a pitch for my
punch in jury concept and even made a
haram character for you
keep an eye out keep kicking butt thank
you i will
wicked felina says the end of your quest
shining light into shadows reveal the
wizard
who is wizard ian will always be the
wizard then who is wisdom
yoda is wisdom who is yoda yoda is tim
tim will always be yoda
okay i caught all of that
gigi player says true power is
competence according to jordan peterson
mm-hmm
yeah i think it's related to authority
you know competence gives gives you the
right to speak into
something yeah i just it's this like
you know whenever the communists get
power they're like we're gonna take the
farm away from the farm
farmer and give it to the farm hands and
then the farm collapses yep it's like
maybe you needed that person to know
what they were doing yeah
is authority derived from power or is
power derived from authority
true power in my understanding comes
from authority
huh and where does authority come from
do you think well competence was one
good
but you know maybe wisdom is another one
right
okay sounds good virtue character
jerome morrow says based on a previous
super chat zombies don't eat brains
because they're zombies
people become zombies because they eat
brains and get the wrong prions
oh no i think you just die when that
happens
what is it called encephalopathy crits
felt jacob disease
oh is that it is yeah it's the shakes
yeah the shakes remember in book of eli
it's like when you buy you gotta hold
your hands and if they're oh no my hands
are shaking look
wait okay there they go oh my gosh oh
what's the story dude bookerville is an
awesome
movie you should watch it oh awesome no
it's a post-apocalyptic and like he goes
to the store and they're like show me
your hands and he like has to hold his
hands up
because when the cannibals are shaking
wow yeah so they're like they want to
know if you're a cannibal or not that
was book of eli right yeah
yeah that movie's awesome great movie
denzel washington
yeah dude that movie's so cool
c.s bowden says the little bugs are most
likely gnats
but they're so tiny we have nats they're
everywhere
we should you know we should do for the
vlog we should make the world's biggest
uh bug zapper
that'd be cool like a tesla tower it
would basically be a giant tesla coil
we built a tesla coil in the parking lot
for the bugs and like
it just wipes like we should see it's
raining bugs because they're all flying
towards it
and then the chickens are having a field
day the moths would
would burst into flames right i probably
that could be a fire wow that would be
awesome
would be pretty cool i feel weird about
coming out to nature and then
slaughtering
all the animals they're trespassing
that's true they are trespassing that's
true and there's so much people to come
see it
yes that way we get it on friday
everybody stand back we're turning on
the coil
maybe michael knowles book signing there
yeah yeah yes
we have to omg puppy says quote power
emanates from the barrel of a gun
technically correct authoritarianism
nick spicer says hey tim love the show
curious if you think the world is
heading towards
the world in harrison bergeron forced
equality and dystopic government rule
well that one was obviously very silly
like people having earpieces that scream
in their ears so they can't think
properly or wearing ugly masks or
something
i mean in a certain sense i think we're
already there
where it's like ian was saying you get a
company and they're like we need someone
who knows how to backflip
have you considered hiring a mexican
person it's like
what does that have to do with the
backflip what backflip
it's like well we need to hire people
who can that's where we're at i feel
like um
purely through like need necessity that
it won't get to that place of harrison
bergeron because i think we'll die off
as a species if we
let ourselves hamstring or kneecap
ourselves as a species so i think it's
just going to be like this
evolution doesn't happen because we want
it to it happens because it has to
happen
so i does that make sense did i clarify
that was that too uh
here's what i think we should do i think
maybe all of us
productive individuals should just one
at a time
start leaving without a word and you
know
go to a specific area where we can be
separate from these uh countries that
support people and extract value from
those who are the hard workers
you know we can do we can leave like a
calling card after we're gone maybe like
some kind of question
something that like people would like
struggle to understand like like um
maybe maybe like calling out someone's
name or something just having them
question it like who is
juan juan galto
who is
how do you say who in spanish
juan galto is that how you say it
yes uh ain rando for those that aren't
familiar
rainforest says third time's the charm
it is the sixth
not the fifth that guarantees a speedy
trail thank you sir for the correction
the fifth amendment is what the rights
to uh remain silent
and um the fifth is more than that
though
yeah i don't remember whatever
constitution is great
all right everybody if you haven't
already smash that like button you can
follow this show on instagram and
facebook at tim cast irl go on facebook
and share hit that smash that share
button on these clips we're putting up
clips from the show
which are very different from the clips
on youtube and they're usually like
making specific points so they're really
fun
and it helps grow the show we want to
obviously leverage facebook to get more
people to go to timcast.com and become
members
we have two vlogs this weekend because
i recently went and got the sig m400
that stephen crowder had sent me so
tomorrow's video is
me going to get it that'll be up around
9am at cast castle so go to youtube.com
and then sunday is when we used it
and also when we brought up the barrett
m82 and fired a 50 bmg at a steel target
rated for 308 which was a whole lot of
fun
you don't want to miss it so go to
youtube.com youtube.comcastcastle check
out the vlog you'll love it subscribe
did you guys want to shout out your
social media or anything
you can find me on twitter at grace is
for you just everything's spelled out
easy enough curtis ian how about you
curtis
you can find me cooking dinner for her
while she's responding to twitter
delicious excellent i accept you're
becoming more healthy
you are engaged with society thank you
have a wonderful evening and find peace
within you it's there oh
i like this i like this ian wisdom
before we leave
i just looked up the fifth amendment
there's a lot in there due process you
can't try somebody twice and
private property and i just wanted to
say if you don't want to get into a
fight with an
alligator in water what you need to do
when you start a conversation
not shoot it that would be violence is
to pin down your definitions before you
even get started just like tim did
tonight with our
definition of critical theory anyway i'm
sarah patchlids on twitter you can
follow me and join me in my journey to
have more followers and sour patch kids
smash that like button on your way out
we do the show monday friday monday
through friday live at 8pm
so we're not going to be necessarily
back tomorrow but with the new show we
are normally it's like we'll see you
monday no now we'll see you tomorrow
at youtube.com cast castle 9am
and then sunday and we are getting
closer and closer to making the vlog
go daily how crazy are we just
more and more shows we're not the
paranormal podcast is not far behind but
the biggest challenge we face is just uh
you know you can only hire so many
people so fast you can't just be like
okay everybody's hired and then you have
no idea what's going on
so we're going as fast as we can but uh
we're getting there so thanks for being
members at timcast.com and we will see
you all next time bye guys
you